alors s'il faut tu sais que j'ai eu 3
comment il aida fond tu aurais parlé
aussi mios et enfin bon il y eut aussi
le passif il en parle ça veut dire que
tout le monde en parle
delos szabados noches
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission pas comme les
autres vous connaissez le principe tout
le monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
vous connaissez ce type voici thierry
lhermitte
tout le monde le mode a été bon soir
thierry lhermitte alors c'est la
première fois que vous venez à tout le
monde en parle on est ravi surtout que
c'est l'émission numéro 69 et je pense
que toutes nos téléspectatrices
apprécieront quand même le geste quand
même on n'a pas inviter n'importe qui tu
sais que cela vous connaissez les
missions alors vous savez quand on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle j'ai entendu
pas d'accord quand ça va être la promo
de votre film c
et si vraiment vous fait des discours
mais vous c'est pas les pas de danger
mais si des fois où on faisait
l'histoire devrait compliquer c'est ça
c'est des gens les gens font ça quand tu
entends des moûts phoenix est supporter
on les comprend ce moment c'est sale
j'avais donc c'est un public
complètement instrumentalisé qui est
entièrement à ma dévotion et qui fait
tout ce que je veux mise à part thierry
lhermitte je recevrai ce soir mais
l'amitié
des alibis
georges marc benamou
les données
matin
[Musique]
surtout ça dure peu après son arme après
ses débuts sont très chauds puis au bout
d'un moment et dans le temps alors pour
présenter l'émission avec moi avant j'ai
eu plein de plein de gens qui ont essayé
et finalement je m'entends très bien
avec lui
c'est
j'ai ses copains et enquête
ouais
bonjour attention pied
et ouais bravo
attention pour arbitrer le blind test il
y aura masyaf héliporté
[Musique]
l'état
m
peter thiel à messieurs alors vous savez
que
tout le monde en parle est une émission
qui est vrai que pied sur les autres
chaînes très copiés sur france 3 très
copiés sur tf1 est en fait ce qui est
surtout que pied ce qui a été copié en
premier c'est cette idée de diffuser
chaque semaine les meilleurs moments de
l'émission précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé
c'est préparé par jean hugues noël la
panne et auxerre non ma fille est en
train d'écrire une pièce pour vous
avantage dehors s'appelle j'en étais sûr
ça va être le sujet principal de la
soirée réussie ils vont venir avec un
col roulé ce que vous préférez en vous
d'affaires moi parce que je préfère en
moi ou peut-être qu'il va très
certainement la plus minable aux ennuis
pour i way
ça va je me suis excusé alors vous le
rencontrer à l'elysée matignon en droit
aujourd'hui disparu et alors il ya un
type qui vient vous dire monsieur
gainsbourg ordonne que vous alliez à sa
table vous dites quoi
ce vieux con qu'il aille se faire [ __ ]
quoi ils arrivent vers vous il vous dit
le vieux con il vient à ta table espèce
de boudin c'était sympa comme entrée en
matière le vieux con vraiment trop
il est très doué dans les sketchs vrai
qu'est ce qu'il ya comment il ya ma
chaîne qui veut aider car c'était bien
david et fiona tan pourquoi je n'étais
pas avec les deux
avant l a6 et les couper ou la chanson a
été deux ans avec les frères jacques oui
font pas des rôles non plus ses
ambitions
il s'est dit je tourne à un joli rôle
avec lui mais j'ai fait les essais rôle
plus important
oui michel arrêt de matinée centre a été
un des inventeurs de la bombe nucléaire
française et vous vous êtes contre la
prolifération des armes atomiques
bah oui des contradictions dans toutes
les familles moi ma mère sonnait non
mais je baise pas donc été socialiste à
l'époque jacques chirac
il aurait pu n'ont jamais réussi à lui
faire signer la demande d'adhésion mais
il venait souvent réunion je réalisais
nous étions là même en bout de sciences
po
j'ai bien copains c'est là qu'il a
défendu la pelle de john g oui justement
je vais tout vous dire il me considérait
comme beaucoup trop réactionnaire pour
lui chirac chirac solide est-ce que
embrasser s'est trompé non ah bon qu'est
ce que c'est que cette philosophie que
vous vous trimballez là c'est pas une
demande mal juin mais ça dépend du
contexte et j'espère bien que non ouais
et succès s'est trompé et pardon sucer
c'est tromper non plus non plus
ouais
l'appareil
un homme pressé de rendre voilà
une idée convoyeur voilà merci beaucoup
thierry lhermitte donc bon soir leurs
riches à main on vous a vu dans le
placard de francis veber votre metteur
en scène du dîner de cons oui 5 millions
d'entrées on vous a vu aussi dans le
prince du pacifique avec patrick timsit
un peu moins d'entrées à millions quand
même a quand même un million oui c'est
pas mal quand même
alors c'est comme vous êtes producteur
je veux 20 kg est si nombre à un million
quand même hein on en espérait plus mal
rentrés dans leurs futures - aussi
rassuré nous vous rentrez dans vos frais
nous redonnerons à un moment tout de
suite vous et plus tellement de blé avec
un indien dans la ville a même vous êtes
justice vous êtes tranquille pour
restant de vos jours
est-ce que c'est pas été abusé par un
rêve de gosse parce que quand vous étiez
petit ou les îles robinson crusoé
ouais et finalement ça vous avez envie
de le faire ce film de toute façon non
oui toute façon mais j'essaie je le
regrette pas c'est un bonheur immense de
le faire et on oublie après on ne reste
que les boules que les bons moments dans
ce programme
ouais l'oeil est passé à non sur la mère
aimait beaucoup la mère et la mère du
sud
un nom sur la mer avec votre épouse
hélène après quinze ans de mariage c'est
ce qu'on appelle le test du tour du
monde en solitaire à 2 oui absolument et
et si le couple résiste à ça après sa
dure pour toute la vie on peut on peut
continuer un peu là vous avez résisté
oui absolument du coup on avait un peu
peur de ça mais vraiment le coup alors
vous revenez cette fois comme acteur
dans un film excellent qui s'appelle le
roman de lulu vous savez comment on fait
ça commençait bien voilà très bien sûr
que vous avez bien c'est bien ben
j'étais au club med
tout le monde sait très démocratique un
balladur l'a fait car la fée giffa le
corps l'a fait c'est très démocratique
alors c'est un film de pierre olivier
scotto avec vous avec claire keim avec
patrick bouchitey cyrielle clair et
thierry beccaro
alors j'avais mon nom bécarre au si si
[Applaudissements]
jégo rien je pense que je vais faire le
pitch & read weepu vierge et faire le
pitch sait déjà ce qu'il faut savoir ne
pas avoir l'air con avec vos amis c'est
que roman valent le roman de lui vu
roman c'est le nom d'un personnage voilà
c'est pas le roman comme un livre un bon
faudrait le dire parce que sinon en
ligue 2 alors roman donc c'est le nom
d'un personnage c'est vous vous aimez
lui vu lui vous m
mais le problème si vous avez 50 ans et
elle 25,1 et alors vous vous posez
beaucoup de problèmes dans ce film pour
savoir si vous devez l'acquitter à cause
de la différence d'âge
elle c'est la gonfle en fait ce qu'il a
gonflé plus c'est pas la différence
d'âge c'est le fait que ça vous pose des
problèmes c'est je voudrais qu'elle me
quittes
voilà c'est ça que c'est pas bien pour
elle qu'elle n'avait qu'un vieux ah oui
c'est un sacrifice extraordinaire
alors elle elle décide de partir tourner
un film aux états unis parce que
l'actrice et puis finalement ne plus
rentrer quoi et puis les sites ou les
deux romans et lulu de vivre trois jours
d'amour et elle espère qu'il va lui
demander de rester bien entendu alors il
ya plein de flashbacks pendant le film
où on voit roman qu'il aime comme un fou
qui essayait de l'acheter dans les bois
de garçon plus jeune
voilà ça n'a jamais marché et donc
pendant trois jours ils scène il se
déchire et quand le lundi arrive alors
ça évidemment le film alors la morale
c'est quoi la morale c'est finalement
quand on aime quelqu'un à très fort on
est prêt il faut être capable de s'en
séparer il faut être capable de lui
rendre sa liberté
le ce mec un peu tordu kerman dans le
film quand ça s'est un peu fuir le
bonheur de peur qu'il ne se sauve il dit
qu'il faut qu'elle s'en aille parce que
il n'est pas fait pour elle qu'elle sera
mieux avec un mec plus jeunes parce que
il veut pas qu'elles vieillissent avec
un vieillard qui vieillit voilà à voir
tout ça étant dans son sinon il ira
c'est une idée du sacrifice ultra
romantique mais ma voix mais oui c'est
ultra inventif se séparer de celle qu'on
aime pour le pas la faire souffrir c'est
quand même presque heureuse haut niveau
ça ira à l'occurrence effectivement dans
la vraie vie s'arrête jamais sinon ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils aient des gens qui
aillent moi je vois pas une ville qui
voudraient profiter pour remettre
personnellement entre nous mais non plus
alors c'est un film excellent au départ
c'est une pièce de théâtre fut à
l'époque alors c'est très bizarre
l'histoire parce que l'auteur de la
pièce s'appelle david des gras et en
fait c'est le père de sandrine kiberlain
qui était expert comptable qui était
patron d'un bar à vin et qui rêvait de
faire du théâtre et qui arrange ou
renvoyer la pièce à sandrine à 100 on
dira que c'était lui
la pièce était magnifique elle a été
jouée donc par sandrine de kiberlain et
gérard darmon
voilà j'ai vu à l'époque aussi oui et
elle quand elle l'a vu était bouleversé
les gays a été choqué par rapport à
beaucoup d'audace beaucoup dans
l'impudeur et l'a compris que c'était
son père elle est allée trouver gérard
darmon effectivement ils ont ils ont
joué tous les deux et ils ont eu un
molière 97 pour la meilleure révélation
théâtrale voilà le problème de
l'histoire c'est que david des cas était
très heureux de voir son film ni sur un
écran depuis qu'il est mort pendant
l'adaptation du film sur son lit
d'hôpital il ya un an en février
en février 2000 en travaillant encore
absolument l'adaptation que ces belles
histoires
c'est très beau moi j'avais accepté le
film avant même de savoir
qui serait le metteur en scène avant que
l'adaptation soit écrite parce que quand
on a la chance de lire des répliques
comme ça de faire des scènes d'amour
aussi belle que ça et c'est ça se rate
pas voilà donc j'ai sauté dessus
regardez à quoi ça ressemble malgré lui
la personne que j'aime le plus au monde
et c'est pour ça qu'ils revenaient de
problème
le premier
[Musique]
fromont
deuxième combien je suis un vieux quand
ça va bien j'arrive tout d'un ministre
c'est un problème pour moi
dans une fouille à dieu un site choisi
un vieux je suis une gérante au film
d'infoman et dans la famille dieu je
demanderai
c'est moi
il
ce qui nous excusez moi je suis rendu
chez sa maîtresse
c'est vrai pour vous draguez l'équipe
jeune ya très peu savaient pas trop en
faire pour vous en débarrasser
tu restes avec moi jusqu'à lundi matin
même les femmes de ménage de leur vie
jour tout va bien dans les 48 heures
[Musique]
deux caches la passion personnage son
âge avec mon expérience c'est inhumain
en même temps c'est extraordinaire merci
petite histoire des circoncisions j'ai
pu penser à ça les petites saucisses
comme ça on n'en fallait extrêmement
petit des prénoms je t'aime beaucoup tu
sais oui
t'aime beaucoup tu sais je me demande
même s'ils avaient pas en train de mai
mais autant que moi je l'aimais
c'est pour ça que tu dois partir j'ai
oublié qu dont un maximum de conneries
tu peux dire dans un minimum de temps
docteur olivier scotto thierry lhermitte
est notre invité ce soir est claire kane
c'est bien ça va marcher parce que c'est
un film très très romantique on a besoin
de choses comme ça j'ai su que ça ne
marche en sais rien mais en tout cas
c'est un beau film et les gens souvent
une poussière dans l'oeil à la fin prêt
vraiment
alors dites moi j'ai vu que le 26 mars
2001 donc dernièrement j'ai été décoré
des insignes de chevalier de la légion
d'honneur par jacques chirac
oui alors moi quand j'ai vu ça je me
suis dit bayan les mecs du splendid là
ça y est quoi ils sont complètement
ils sont complètement rentré dans le
rang les trublions sont décidément bien
récupéré par le système
et puis en fait pas du tout j'ai appris
que c'était surtout pour votre
engagement face aux problèmes de
l'enfance trisomique
ouais ouais ouais c'est très gentil très
très gentille magritte et qui s'est
retrouvé des armes et d'un seul coup
ah oui oui on va aller mais qu'ils
allaient dire ah mais non on est
vraiment à n'importe qui et voilà alors
pas n'importe qui c'est que les trucs à
chercher des décorations je me disais et
finalement non vous êtes très discret là
dessus oui bah ça c'est je vais vous
dire quand quand on n'est pas concerné
directement par ce problème la cire
quand on n'a pas d'enfants handicapés ce
qui est mon cas on n'a pas trop voix au
chapitre alors on est obligés d'être
discret mois au début je pensais que
c'était sympa que dd que donc on pouvait
en parler tout simple j'ai reçu des
lettres pas sympa du tout donc je me
suis dit que je pense que je vais pas de
légitimité pour en parler mais derrière
en tout cas bravo
on va parler joue un peu
alors votre vrai nom votre vrai nom vous
le dites jamais votre vrai nom quand je
dis jamais je serai bah ouais c'est
e-retail serait-ce pas terrible non non
mais c'est vrai thierry lhermitte c'est
bien hein pourquoi dermique ben j'ai
trouvé que c'était sympa comme ça ça
faisait un peu solitaire avec l'armée
peut être qu'à passer sa vie dans une
voix celle du splendid
ouais c'est ça me met deux d'un côté un
petit peu particulier ouais lhermitte
j'aurais dû prendre un pseudo j'aurais
pas pris les armes il a non mais je sais
bien mais c'est pour ça que j'ai jamais
cherché qualifier votre vraiment parce
que je n'avais pas pseudo lhermitte on
se dit quand on s'appelle lhermitte
c'est un truc qu'on n'a pas pu choisir
je sais je sais une est une erreur je
pense qu'il s'est lancé thierry tu
ailles madame déjà je serai alors
famille bourgeoise non attends ouais on
va me gonfler avec ça maintenant pendant
je sais pas vous mais c'est pas vrai cg
je joue le jeu c'est pas vrai c'est mon
vrai nom taye moreno
vous évoquez sinon ça va être un
cauchemar ça fait trente pris dans les
dents les machins et donc c'est vrai
c'est tout
vous êtes d'une famille bourgeoise way
grande bourgeoisie ou on perd et et
cadres supérieurs et bon air et ses
journalistes ouais ouais enfin quand
même un peu une soeur qui est devenu
décoratrice si votre prof d'anglais en
face cammas et et vouliez de prof de
maths
oui oui j'imagine et les enfants voient
un prof de maths comme thierry lhermitte
arrivé j'ai heureusement que j'ai
rencontré blé mes camarades du splendid
alors à neuilly évidemment vous allez au
collège à neuilly au lycée pasteur lycée
pasteur à neuilly et vous rencontrez ça
c'est très bizarre parce que c'est
marrant comment les choses se passent
dans la vie c'est un truc qui me
surprend toujours parce que dans cette
école il y avait des gérard jugnot
les christian clavier nous étions
quatrièmes ensemble vous commencez à
décider de monter des spectacles vous
montez jousse torride edward albee blanc
vous l'avez rencontré plus tard en même
temps que en même temps que nous serions
jouer une pièce de michel blanc sa
première pièce qui c'était la concierge
est tombé dans l'escalier
oui alors il était comment la clavier de
résister comme maintenant offert jeudi
réalité déjà délirant clavier comme
savaient plus de cheveux pour certains
et aussi oui oui assez assez délirant
oui délirant junion rats de cinémathèque
jugnot ouest il était chef du ciné club
donc il faisait découvrir le chien
andalou bunuel the times des trucs comme
ça
ouais et blanc et je vais très bien du
piano michel bulawa il voulais être
concertiste avoir pillé et ça tombait
ouais alors dans ce lycée pasteur mais
j'ai pas de chance parce que bon c'est
une bonne demande vraiment des joyeux
drilles mais il n'y avait pas de filles
banon à l'époque c'est en effet c'est
après 68 que l'aller vous êtes parti
l'année d'après il définit c'est devenu
mixte après dance était vraiment
gonflant me posais pas connu les vices
et miquelon non c'était c'était horrible
un truc qui paraît une évidence
aujourd'hui c'est bizarre où vous ont
fait entendre leurs dix essais pamic se
disent ah ben on va quand je suis arrivé
dans un lycée mixte et eric j'ai
l'impression d'être dans une confiserie
je suis bien heureusement j'avais
apprise plus qu'avant parce que j'ai
plus jamais rien pris ils n'étaient pas
en train de dire qui est beaucoup plus
jeune que moi c'est pas ça on allait à
l'enfance noir oui c'est ça je pense me
suis 50° l'âge j'ai 48 ans est beaucoup
plus jeune que moi
ah bon ça spectateurs de dominicis mx1
parce que j'étais dans un collège de
curé un jour chez elle dans un lycée et
c'était mixte évidemment sortant de chez
les curés j'avais vu des robes mais l
autre chose dessous donc là d'un coup
alors vous n'étiez pas très snob me suis
un peu baba il vous souvient très bas
vous soulevez un peu on était un peu à
l'écart ou et puis oui on était très
bavarde des détenus craignos ouais alors
vous faites vos premiers films tous à
l'époque le premier film en 16 mm
financé par par votre grand-mère en
partie d'angeles bordée des sous dans ma
femme à mes pieds à droite à gauche
avait fait payer en effet avance sur
recette en effet payé le dauphin
pour moi c'était quoi s'il était un peu
comme au genou et bunuel ce s'appelait
alors attends désespoir de cathodes ça
veut dire quoi
ballard et la cathode c'est le la langue
le côté les à l'anode et la cathode dans
le rouge merci et
c'est un peu n'importe quoi c'est très
bête c'est très intello et très très
bête ou quoi qu'on a écrit ça qu'avec
jugnot qui avait filmé lui-même et
c'était un chef-d'oeuvre qui a été
heureusement perdu alors vous n'avez
plus la bien alors après le lycée ben on
va vous allez auquel vous rencontrez le
café théâtre
hélas hélas vous connaissez marie-anne
chazel coluche et balasko et vous fait
le deuxième splendide en fait si vous
construisez vous même on construire on a
vu le café de la gare et en même temps
que coluche construisait le vrai chic
parisien nous on était en face aux
construit splendide avec valérie
mairesse avec balasko déjà marie-anne
chazel et les premières pièces uniques
ya eu des noms en bleu ce travail
ouais le matin dans le froid oui
absolument déchaîné dans les premiers
jeux à 1 maintenant vous êtes tous des
bourgeois super riches ou là le
splendide vous aimez les chiffres du
bureau c'était ça moi j'aime ça ouais
alors après il ya eu un amour
coquillages et crustacés qui sont
devenus les bronzés le père noël est une
ordure 6 la wii la wii
et puis il ya des pièces que vous allez
jouer comme ça je parle 500 fois le père
nous on est ça tourne à jouer 27 ans
sans interruption sur donc les bronzés
on a dû le faire enfin hambourg qui h 30
deux ans et le père noël une d'une
saison et demie ça doit faire 400 fois
mais vous dites quoi que je fasse je
serai toujours le mec des bronzés
jusqu'à la fin de mes jours vous pourrez
vraiment ça ben pour wealth ça passe à
la télé sans arrêt donc enfin
régulièrement donc bas
c'est comme ça et des trucs qui marque
je me rappelle tournant avec avec noir
et il y avait en était là et puis il y
avait des mecs qui arrivait et qui
disait hussain chênois ya vraiment un
film dans lequel vraiment je vous ai
bien aimé c'est le vieux fusil
aulas et voilà c'est comme ça et dès que
je voyais des mecs s'approchait de noir
et je m'éloignais je faisais nous
célébrons joie alors en 83 la bande du
splendid commencer un petit peu à se
séparer
et pour vous c'est pas facile parce
qu'avec la tête que vous avez on peux
pas vous donner de second rôle non mais
c'est vrai bah c'est à ce moment là
quand on s'est séparés
là je commence à voir les premiers rôles
mais avant jugnot et là il a travaillé
bien avant moi même bien avant de nous
tous il pendant que nous on trime est
dans le dans la cave a construit le
splendide lui il allait jouer avec
lautner 20 gauche intérêts on lui
faisait payer très cher ouais parce que
quand ils revenaient l'ignoble ouais là
les secours promettent d'en douter a
fait du temps alors sérieux non parce
que quand on s'est arrêté de travailler
ensemble après le père noël j'ai
commencé à faire le des films tout seul
l'année prochaine si tout va bien et que
gianni vit c'est parti à ce moment là on
en est tous partis d'autres termes votre
foyer production ses nuits d'ivresse
avec balasko 1
vous allez d'il ya quelques temps que
vous vouliez être plutôt producteurs
dans l'avenir que acteurs est-ce que
après le prince du pacifique vous
maintenez cette déclaration ben je
maintiens pour faire des films qui dans
lequel je suis engagé totalement qui me
tiennent à coeur vraiment comme le
prince du pacifique un seul mois
ça va pas décourager dans ce sens je me
suis juste dit que en fait j'étais pas à
ses producteurs pour faire beaucoup de
films qui me concernait pas directement
qui le passionnait pas complètement le
prince m'a passionné jeu si c'était à
refaire je le referais encore allez vous
leur ferez remarquer sur tf1 le dimanche
soir ça fait un malheur en tout cas pour
moi vous êtes acteur qui s'appelle le
roman de lulu avec claire keim film de
pierre olivier scotto
le pire est à venir le pire est à venir
thierry lhermitte est ce que vous
suggérez mentir oui monsieur moi pas du
tout tombe bien je dis toujours avec la
seconde affaire l'interview mensonge en
la bouche pendant les jean galle
[Musique]
dès qu'il ya pas d'afficher un bonheur
cette émission et d'eads a fist au
mexique c'est insensé j'ai reçu un email
et au mexique n'ont pas lui il ya débat
fils thomert envie que des gens qui
regardent l'émission au mexique qui
bouge pendant le jingle qui sans cette
histoire alors à l'époque de deux
pasteurs
vous avez des relations homosexuelles et
que gérard jugnot
bah oui il faut enfin me gêne mais c'est
vrai que récemment c'est vrai que
récemment vous avez décidé de faire un
petit essai tous les deux à nouveau
ensemble
il veut pas voilà voilà le problème
c'est qu'on veut parent voilà c'est vrai
je pense qu'il faut rien n'est perdu je
te le dit gérard voit la caméra je te le
digère je suis encore là et je crois je
t'attendrai toute ma vie bien thierry
tail en continu dont vous avez fait
votre service militaire dans légion
étrangère
vous avez eu une aventure avec un
sergent un ancien de l'indo qui était le
fils naturel du général de gaulle ça ne
s'est pas beaucoup non effectivement
c'est horrible c'est comme renault
et alors mais
quand on sait lire entre les lignes des
des articles de fond est celle à qui on
le comprend effectivement il était beau
monde et il sentait bon le sable chaud
alors au début d'une tournée j'étais
gigolo pour payer les travaux
vous avez souffert de ça ça vous a
humilié nom et que je ne crache pas non
monsieur g g suhr ag rendu tg rendu
heureux croyez moi vous êtes donné du
bonheur
vous êtes un film porno le propos de
premiers films pour passer un film porno
avec brigitte lahaie
vous avez une aventure de plusieurs mois
avec elle et elle dira elle dit vous
quand elle parle de vous elle dit il
aurait pu être un super rocco siffredi
là je peux pas répondre à cette question
vous avez des chances avait déchaîné les
foules
là je ne peux même pas nombreux merci
brigitte votre boîte échangiste préféré
à paris en ce moment c'est quoi c'est
pas tout à fait d'un dieu c'est hugh
laurie thérèse alors hélène elle prend
comment votre aventure avec claire keim
là pendant le tournage du film le roman
de lui voilà une habitude énorme
oui c'est bien cette fois mes chances
mais qu'en même temps vous êtes ensemble
ces trois m'échapper 21 22 25 ou
éventuelle
oui ces habitués bien sûr j'ai pas de
problème non non non non aucun est
claire elle supporte que vous aviez
quand même temps encore la maison elle
si c'est plus dur pour elle ce dimanche
en musique cet objectif est obligé
d'aller j'avais envie d'aller voir les
enfants et tout comme ça tout ce qui
prime en huit jours dont thierry tu
ailles vous êtes un grand ami de jean
marie le pen n'hésite pas désolé un
petit peu par la disparition du front
national du paysage politique français
sont ils se sont gâchées vraiment la
libye
ils ont déconné et vraiment quand on a
des cantons et des beaux amis comme ça
ce se brouiller pour une histoire de cul
c'est un bon show avec sa nounou
vous êtes le plus riche en fait des
anciens du splendid vous investissez
beaucoup dans les airs aux senteurs dans
le nord de l'europe et vous avez une
spécialité c'est la russe fait venir des
camions de russan fait d'eux des
slovènes
ça marche bien est spécialisé dans le
pays de l'est vous j'avais des amis qui
bêtement on a mis en duos la vie qui
vient de se faire incarcérer mais très
bêtement mais ils pourront fournissait
c'était sympa mais qu'est ce qu'elles
ont le plus les filles de l'est pourquoi
voulez vous fait tenir par camion par
wagons entiers sont sincères à
l'association c'est ça elle compte pas
l'oms a déclaré je voudrais mourir comme
elvis presley bourré de tranquillisants
bourré de sucreries en train de sauter
des lolitas vous maintenez ça oui c'est
une sorte d'apothéose c'est vrai que
devant votre place vous essayer de
chanter comme elvis et tout ça c'est que
pour moi est un bon aller les russes et
les lolitas
calendrier scotto et
non
vous n'avez pas quand on est un peu seul
là on est deux garçons oui ça serait
plutôt bien j'en avais une petite
gonzesses ça serait plus sympa ouais si
mélanie thierry
après claire keim et nani touché à une
épaule
comment ça va mais très heureux de vous
avoir moi je vous avais vus dans le film
de timsit justement quasimodo d'el paris
c'est trop génial ans la nièce sebha
fiche 69
non mais je présente pas à regarder
juuju mon garçon fiche 69 c'est pas de
la rigolade fiche 69 les rôles sont
inversés c'est une tradition dans cette
émission
donc c'est vous qui allez poser une
question mais comme c'est la fiche 69 de
l'émission 69
c'est un double 69 donc vous allez me
poser une question à moi une question à
thierry lhermitte voilà c'est sympa
c'est très sympa jeunesse que je vous
écoute mel eg je suis prêt à commencer
par thierry oui pour moi je me posais la
question à savoir quand on a choisi
d'être comédien si la vie de comédien
était compatible avec une vie de famille
en fait parce que c'est quelque chose
qui s'est fait peur
ouais bah ça ça que ça fasse peur c'est
sûr mais faut avouer mais vivre dans le
danger alors oui si la preuve j'ai rien
au contraire il a fait le test du voyage
alliant le solitaire à 2 le tour du
monde avec sa femme ils ont survécu à ce
voyage leur amour a survécu donc la
réponse est c'est la réponse est oui
même si c'est dangereux
les comédiens non
by la peur il a peur il dirait que c'est
marqué je suis marié aussi - rassurez
vous posez moi une question maintenant
j'ai un petit peu j'aurais aimé savoir
quand on est un bel homme il faut le
dire si ce n'était pas difficile de se
voir vieillir
[Applaudissements]
v
un ami parce que c'est une question que
je mourrais envie de poser à thierry
lacombe bien que non c'est vrai quand
j'ai vu apparaître la de chaque côté là
comme ça là de petites rides qui
descendent
je me suis dit mon garçon ça ça commence
quoi si ça fait chier voilà donc c'était
la question 69 de l'émission en 69
maintenant on peut continuer voilà vous
êtes oui alors vous étiez à la fiche de
quasimodo d'el paris cette hausse est à
l'affiché d'un film qui s'appelle 15
août avec charles berling richard berry
jean pierre darroussin un film de
patrick alessandrin je suis le pitch
alors trois pères de famille qui
rejoignent leurs femmes à la baule pour
le week-end du 15 août mais leurs femmes
lassées par quinze jours de pluie avec
les gosses sur les bras elle se sont
cassés
donc ils se retrouvent comme des cons
avec les mômes sur les bras pendant le
week-end du 15 août
évidemment il pleut le scénario a été
écrit par la femme du réalisateur
ce qui fait que c'est un peu tendancieux
quand même à être contrôlés mec ça je
vois là c'est à dire que les mecs style
au bout de trois jours avec leurs mômes
dans cette maison ils prennent
conscience de leur erreur ils se rendent
compte qu'ils sont conduits comme des
porcs etc etc etc
voilà alors il ya trois mecs qui jouent
très très bien ils sont excellents la
berling darroussin il ya beaucoup de
scènes où ils sont tous les trois
ensemble et vous vous êtes la fille fait
la belle fille vous êtes là la belle
fille de richard berry voilà vous êtes
très très sexy dans le film aux attraits
à lui
cocody est soumis nous ont fait les
allumeuses lé peste à souhait
parce qu'elle est très très méchante
[ __ ] c'est le coup elle est très très
gentil c'est difficile de résister non
on va voir à quoi ça ressemble milow et
les huîtres sont trop grasses et les
langoustines fraîches et le pas il sait
transformer en choc au bn
vous n'êtes pas contacté faire vous même
les courses marie-claude obligés 105 3
mois vous remboursera ici axa avant ou
après que des failles et la maison bois
non c'est pas une légère note enfin
autonomes qu'elle ait pris des vacances
vos femmes parce que moi je tiens pas de
joie à cette voie là
à
ça
je dirai rien
même si je savais je dirai rien
entièrement solidaire à laquelle
j'espère quand même bien s'éclater
commence à s'éclater à prendre leur pied
lâche et ç'a donné si tu préfères je lis
que tu cherches dedans tout de suite
sinon vous pouvez nous laisser s'il vous
plaît c'est quand même avec ma voiture
qu'elles sont parties s'éclater julie
julie je te préviens tu arrêtes ton
petit jeu tout de suite sinon sinon plus
rien plus rien plus plus de soirées plus
de quoi pas plus de sorties plus rien
rien rien et rien vu t'as pas le droit
d'interdire quoi que ce soit de toute
manière m'a dit j'aimerais faire ce que
je voulais maintenant jusqu'à preuve du
contraire allez pas là alors que moi oui
alors c'est à moi que ma mère parce
qu'un tournage en ayant encore figure
toi que tu vas tu t'intéresses robin a
tenu bien réussi sa maman il est bon
résultat
jean patrick alessandrin avec des rimes
darroussin et bien et mélanie thierry
qui est notre invité ce soir ça s'est
bien passé le tournage très très sympa
très sympa alors les trucs bizarres
comme dans le film a d'abord il ya
richard berry les toubibs design bmw et
loue une baraque pourri avec deux
copains comme incompréhensible ça ne
pouvait pas vous quoique richard berry
soit médecin où on a vu pire
la vutek si boys non non c'est pas ça
c'est que cette maison après maison et
son nom ils sont une chouette à 3 pour
le wind baraque comme ça c'est un peu
bizarre non c'est vrai que j'ai pas
pensé mais c'est d'abord les femmes qui
vont dans cette maison celles ci sont
radins il avait pris cette maison-là
vollard femmes et ça c'est une
explication serrée j'ai pas pensé
alors il ya un truc est pire tu vois une
copine dans le film et qui s'appelle
comment stéphanie oui elle est charmante
là si tu nous regardes pour envoyer des
mails avec ton portable
non elle est charmante la petite ans que
je comprends pas c'est qu'à un moment
elle attend richard berry tout nu dans
la chambre de richard berry quand ils
arrivent ils la voient et il lui dit
sohrabi toi sort de la gamine de 16 ans
comment ouais ouais enfin c'est richard
berry
dans la saison elle était plus jeune et
pas qu'elle avait 16 ans être un peu
plus à l'est un peu plus un gitan la vie
ce serait pas c'est passé de mode la
pédophilie bête non c'est pas moi c'est
la pédophilie ça c'est de la dauphine
oui exact à la même chose vos parents
s'inquiètent pour vous toujours non
parce que quand vous avez commencé le
métier parce que c'est votre jules qui
s'inquiètent mais quand j'ai commencé le
métier c'est vos parents qui
s'inquiétait non il s'implique toujours
un petit peu à lyon
ils me font confiance ils savent que
j'ai la tête sur les épaules je venais
pas du tout ce milieu là vous c'est
votre père était directeur de l'entrepôt
de surgelés fonctionne il est toujours
dans le salue d'ailleurs s'appelle
monsieur thierry lui oui c'est son vrai
nom vous et gardez votre vrai nom est
entièrement contrairement à thierry tu
ailles bon papa de série de taille non
plus votre mère avait préparatrice en
pharmacie
oui elle peut avoir des trucs un peu non
oui ah ouais c'est bien d'avoir une mère
qui doit dans une femme c'est une
enfance heureuse on fait comme si tu y
es petit vous étiez un vilain petit
canard
mouah ah oui pas du tout mais on vous
appelez le babouin
on n'est pas content tu regardes je suis
allée l'intérim du clan babouins non
vous êtes tellement jolie maintenant
c'est pas grave tu as besoin
et pourquoi mais je crois qu'on va
pouvoir vous appelez le babouin
non mais déjà j'ai un petit nez de
cochon au nom
alors tout de suite face enfin pas du
tout vous est charmante enfin j'espère
que vous avez pas de complexes physiques
non à bondir une école des fans un peu
tout
vous étiez petit tour vous appelez de
babouins et vous rentriez ampleur à la
maison c'est vrai parce que j'avais mon
amoureux qui était pas mon rôle moi qui
me traitait de babouins alors j'étais
malheureux veut évidemment maintenant
que ça se regarde à la télé est là et
bien regardez maintenant
et alors vous en vouliez vraiment basque
à l'âge de 13 ans très très tôt donc
vous vous rentrez dans une agence de
casting s'appelle bout'chou et dans
cette agence de casting
je tiens à signaler il ya eu séverine
ferrer l'ami du dalaï lama
séverine si nous regarde
oui c'est vrai à chaque vainqueur avec
faudel qu'est-ce qu'elle fait d'avoir le
dalaï lama pour le raconter sa peine de
coeur warnex aller voir le curé de la
paroisse pas du tout ces grands services
et le dalaï lama tout de suite
il y avait aussi ludique brillant voilà
c'était indien alindien dans la vie
rapporté énormément d'argent pour
essayer ce qui lui permet de faire le
prince du pacifique voilà alors
non mais c'est vrai cette viande est
hachée bout d'chou la wii vous faisiez
quoi depuis plus comme ça bref en guise
de famille ouais c'était ma première et
puis des petits téléfilm j'avais fait
des petits téléfilm d'études sitcom
après visite chez un petit mannequin de
choses témoin et pourtant vous n'êtes
pas très grande
est-ce que vous à vous et votre taille
la télévision oui il m 58 58 57 déjà
vous
non mais attends c'est un médecin quand
cet ennemi alors j'aimerais rajouter les
d'accord ok on vous la corde vous avons
dit c'est au dessus votre location en
fait c'est pas d'être mannequin ni quoi
que ce soit vous y êtes bookeuse dans l'
agence bulgare in fait un stage et la
boutonné mannequin en fait et vos
copines sont très jalouse de vous ça
vous a vu à faire vous à l'adversité du
monde entier depuis tout petit j'ai à
ceux qui vous traitez de babouins
ensuite quand vous êtes mannequins dont
vous êtes obligé de quitter l'école
tellement ils vous embêter ce n'était
pas toujours facile et difficile à gérer
assumer aussi ce que j'étais jeune je le
suis toujours
mais à 14 ans c'est vrai que c'est
difficile de se prononcer une figure
c'est vrai que des pharaons ont battu
c'est vrai que ça a été une période
assez violente quand même ouais mais
pourquoi parce que tu passes à la télé
bah oui parce que les filles étaient
jalouses en plus c'était la période où
on parlait beaucoup des mannequins que
ça faisait rêver toutes les jeunes
filles de 13 14 ans moi j'avais la
chance de rentrer dans une grande agence
donc automatiquement et à cette jalousie
qui a pris le dessus et c'était pas tous
les jours facile à la souffleur non non
maintenant que j'ai repensé à me fait
rire mais quand
[Musique]
bien alors en février 2000
vous viviez encore chez vos parents et
vous disiez quand je rentre le soir à la
maison on mange ensemble en famille et
si un bon fils on le regarde ensemble en
famille c'est fini ça non à votre julie
vous les parents et lui lécher ses
parents aussi assez cool vous réagiriez
comment si vous retrouviez dans la
situation de lulu c'est à dire claire
keim dans le film dans lequel joue
thierry lhermitte de le roman du luth
voyez quoi imaginer vous soyez de
thierry lhermitte
je suis parti je le crois pas
attendez vous à un poignet c'est moi ou
pas forcément moi on peut imaginer ouais
ça peut être l'autre des trucs a les
yeux marrons alors dites pas tirer
parquet très sérieux par thierry
lhermitte vous êtes la seule fille que
je connaisse qui ne sont pas tirés par
thierry lhermitte moi ce serait pas
grave au second défaut je suis quand
même nom elle venait elle voulait dire
n'est pas attirée par les vieux c'est ça
que tu voulais dire c'est ça la matière
dans les vieux c'est attirer bon ben
voilà bien alors on va enquêter comme un
petit peu sur sur vous sur votre vie
comme vous êtes très jeune on va faire
une interview première fois vous savez
en embauchant
où
le premier mensonge auto quoi par
exemple je sais pas mais cory la prévert
des labos de la maternelle je serai pas
le trait menteuse faut s'en méfier
je serai hélène je viens d'aller
chercher tout de suite thierry lhermitte
votre premier choc ya pas très longtemps
1 oui oui on va trop en parler alors
votre première baffe
c'était avec mon papa
j'étais petit il voulait dormir il était
fatigué c'est un dimanche après midi
moi j'étais très nerveuse courait dans
tous les sens j'étais avec mon petit
magnétophone et je faisais peut-être un
petit peu de bruit c'était peut-être la
goutte qui a fait déborder le vase on
supprime sa mère et pourtant on ne vous
le voulez pas vous habitait toujours
chez lui oui votre premier aïd al qaïda
seul un stage là ils ont besoin de se
sentir aimé désiré merci ma petite votre
premier baiser sans la langue la
maternelle ouais mais j'avais pas de
chance parce que j'étais amoureuse d'un
garçon qui me trouvais pas joli non plus
du coup il ya son copain ou partie des
copains et d'ailleurs c'était une
tournante
donc ça c'était sans la langue à votre
premier baiser avec la londe
treize ans au lol alors ça c'est fait le
même inhumé le lendemain matin dix ans
est définie bah ouais c'est dégueulasse
un accord qu'elle briseuse de coeur la
première fois tout seul
non c'est une question alors j'vais vous
dire la vérité moi cette question je
n'avais pas pensé et j'ai reçu non mais
c'est vrai j'ai reçu un email d'un mec
qui me dit quand tu fais l'interview
première fois tu te demandes toujours la
première fois de la première fois à 3
pourquoi tu demande pas la première fois
tout seul vous en souvenez pas non
jamais tout seul non ah bon la première
fois deux j'étais jeune homme fait x gen
globalement à bord la patience maman
oulala c'est que j'ai deux filles là ça
ne m'inquiète pas ce que je ressens ce
soir maintenant on y note elle vous
couchez première fois à troyes bon ça
vous intéresse pas c'est pas trio du
tout du tout à 4 non plus donc encore
j'arrête là c'est pas les chiffres pairs
ces cas les banques au premier chagrin
d'amour à 15 1 à 15 ans déjà vous avez
tout fait ou à l'âge de 15 ans et
stéphane c'était la première fois que je
tombais amoureuse première fois que je
me donnais à quelqu'un vous avez
souffert d'un mois j'étais folle
amoureuse lui ne met pas du tout
pourrait donc c'était juste pour tirer
son coup comment te dire vulgairement
donc j'en étais malade après cela vous a
commencé à boire première crise d'accor
première cuite et mais j'ai jamais une
première crise c'est ce soir
alors jamais vous n'êtes jamais avec
accor inverse vers ta puce à l'oreille
c'est bien pour les pétards 15 16 ans 16
ans pardon c'est 7 à 16 ans oui j'ai dit
ça parce que votre mère regard non non
non c'est vrai c'est grave et bourges
quelque chose que j'aime pas comment vos
émissions vous poser la question sur
l'eau cabanis d'accord hervé première
cigarette 14 ans ouais premier valium
pas encore bravo two félicite
jerry dans 15 ou le bac 5
sandra
avec mary darroussin et berling
bon quelques email avant de continuer
par rapport aux invités de la semaine
dernière alors beaucoup demand sujet
d'accès le taf on sait que ces deux là
font kiffer la météo à canal qui a dit
qu'elle était célibataire et qu'elle
aimerait bien que l'on peut lancer des
appels ici vous avez pas besoin je les
fais un petit peu oui on peut lancer des
appels ça marche on a marié larusso ici
c'est pas facile facile alors michael
dahan de paris les volontaires il est
volontaire pour axel de la faune donc il
écrit à la prod qui fait suivre dans ces
cas là on a un service spécialisé
les pizzas lance du sexe beaucoup
d'e-mails sur l'intérêt que kamel porte
et axelle laffont alors au sujet de
kamel qu'on me dit c'est valérie
augustin de cholet qui me dit comment un
mec francs comme toi en parlant de moi
qui ai vraiment lentilles drucker
comment peux tu dire que tu aimes la
musique de kamel et ben je réponds je
maintiens j'aime la musique de cannelle
parce qu'il fait de belles mélodies
s'est bien produit voilà julien miro de
la grâce il me dit titi m'appelle titi
il se demande j'ai pas une relation
intime il entendu pas d'une relation
intime entre bruno masure et moi non
c'est pas moi c'est le caire
et maintenant j'accueille stomy bugzy
yazid aït
toi ça va à la pêche des taux élevés
dans un film qui sort le 11 avril qui
s'appelle de l'amour avec virginie
ledoyen mar sodupe et jean françois
stévenin et bruno putzulu réalisé par
jean françois richet alors on va en
parler mais d'abord on va prendre un
petit peu de jus ou nouvelle stomie sur
le plan musical vous en êtes où plan
médical je vais faire une petite tournée
dans toutes les banlieues des petites
salles de 600 personnes mais personne
dans sa chauffe bien et je sortir un
nouveau single dans un monde peu près
mon très bien je vous me répondez sur le
même ton que je vous posais la question
didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]
on a là
oh
membres
les étages
j'allais un peu
sorte de gage et leurs tueurs
des conseils et une
pis ça ça sort le 12 juin c'est vraiment
fière surprise à ses biens après j'ai
l'impression que votre style se
radicalise un peu non ouais c'est fini
les rigolades
fini les conneries c'est quoi tes puis
un lover ou quoi non c'est fini
maintenant j'ai inverse
à 9h20 vos larmes alors c'est un voleur
s'était avons encore warner il ya une
hygiène chose pour tous là c'est le
temps de revenir en rab dhure way est
rempli pour les disques d'or j'ai dit
que mes ordures je reviens au ram dire
non mr il est génial parce que vous
savez quand il cotait à un moment il est
un peu des cases comme ça alors il
arrivait chez des gens et puis piquer
des trucs et puis voyez les photos il
voyez les photos de la famille il a
tellement bon coeur qu'il essaie des
trucs
alors qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient ils
allaient dans les bureaux piquer des
ordinateurs parce que là il n'est pas la
photo des propriétaires il a bon coeur
donc on les retours au retour dû
renoncer vraiment ouais bientôt avec
ministère amer plan b ou là mais on est
là pour parler de cinéma la wii alors
dans les deux cinémas alors d'accord
vous êtes une star de cinéma maintenant
on n'en est pas là c'est ainsi bien sûr
non valide la tournée quand même ouais
non je vous proche donne les dates dont
on était au courant de tout ça à temps
c'est mon boulot
il s'évertue anciens
donagh on va faire un peu la tournée là
[Musique]
alors le vin le 20 avril à marseille le
5 mai à nanterre le 7 mai à toulon le 13
à saint germain en laye le 16 mai
toujours à bordeaux le 17 à toulouse et
le 18 à lyon voilà alors vas-y tu
bonsoir alors vous aviez sorti un album
aussi avant l'ère du cinéma ça plaît je
suis l'arabe mais ça va très bien marché
c'était un peu plus engagés que ce tome
i est plus engagé que vous les femmes
pressées sur mer et textuellement saad
ehret pas trop à ce qui allait aux
influences qui en ce moment dans le hip
hop c'est à dire les termes argotiques
j'ai fait ça plus textuel donc ça n'a
pas trop intéressé ce que le rap
intéressant général vous allez remettre
ça j'espère vous êtes engagé voit un peu
quand même dans le mouvement
l'intégration la banlieue tout ça non un
peu moins maintenant mais je l'étais pas
mal et c'est comme ça que j'avais
rencontré jean françois richet c'est
comme ça que j'ai rencontré jean
françois
depuis qu'il est une star de cinéma
effet plus la pomme en islam si bien on
fait ça alors
bien je tiens beaucoup à ça donc de
l'amour le pitch donc maria interprété
par virginie ledoyen qui vit chez des
parents vieillissants dans une cité son
père c'est jean marc thibault c'est tout
dire l es chômeurs en stage et le gagne
2000 balle par mois dans une usine de
sièges
elle parle de son allée de quitter son
boulot mais elle est toujours là et en
parle avec sa copine linda qui est jouée
par marceau doper leur extraordinaire
cette afrique je connaissais pas alors
heureusement
heureusement virginie ledoyen un petit
ami qui s'appelle karim et qui joué par
yazid circuit c'est votre premier film
vous c'est le deuxième en fait le
premier n'est pas encore sorti il
sortira après tout de suite il est une
scène danois io c'est une loyale mecs se
nourrit de boulot et voilà c'est comme
ça alors karim il a toujours évité les
emmerdes
son seul luxe et sa bm et il a acheté
sur dix ans est son meilleur ami
c'est vous manu donc vous vous est cher
ça c'est sûr c'est pas trop un rôle de
composition à vous êtes dragueur et
glandeur
c'est pas dur à jouer en même temps
c'est un dragueur très très maladroit
ouais alors dombasle avis et balade en
voiture cinéma un bonheur ordinaire pour
échapper un quotidien un peu triste ou y
et puis la vie de maria bascule et le
film aussi d'ailleurs
elle vole inscrite dans nos supermarchés
elle refuse de rendre vigiles et voilà
et là c'est l'enchaînement tragique
commence enfin je peux à peine de faire
cette tête c'est du cinéma
c'est un film non ils sont là on dirait
que après cinq semaines
enfin nous touche quand vous parlez de
ouais bah oui c'est pas très drôle
elle refuse de londres vigiles elle est
emmené dans un commissariat dans ce
commissariat un type qui est sympa qui
jouait par bruno putzulu qui est tout le
bon flic pascal public sympa et un
moment ils se cassent et il dit à son
collègue ben tu veux à la surveiller et
le collègue c'est jean françois stévenin
jeu mais bertrand dans le film et il la
viole
après voir le film après ça ça donne
envie d'amour d'amour un film d'action
la valeur un film d'action c'est
toujours pareil ça me sens vraiment pas
question qu un mois je fais comme moi
aussi oui c'est un bon fond d'amour
c'est toujours au caire kéké darbo et
pas un film français
bien évidemment vins français les
battant par ok
bonsoir 4 passes pro film d'amour
ah ça pour toi surnom à qui stephen
crédit les in store pour moi
mademoiselle lui-même suivre ses pas
m'en veuillez me suivre s'il vous plaît
voilà ce que tu contemples inquiétez pas
monsieur van peebles et gentil tu tiens
ta copine à moi je suis là pour faire
mon boulot je suis pas là pour vous
faire chier mais j'ai pas envie de me
faire virer
[Musique]
de l'amour de jean françois richet dans
un cinéma près de chez vous à partir du
11 avril s'affirme un peu militant dans
maintenant ouais si on veut toutes
façons ne peut pas s'empêcher
jean-françois comme il est assez
politisé il peut pas s'empêcher de
mettre des petits ingrédients mais c'est
vraiment un film sur l'amour basée sur
le sentiment plus que sur le
militantisme
je vais pas leur contrôle ainsi pour
servir un film c'est pas comme si je
venais à la musique pour servir du stomy
bugzy pour tu vois je suis quand l
acteur enfin quand vous êtes acteur vous
avez une
un autre comportement que quand vous
êtes un jeune chanteur ont fait partie
du on est on est on est les pièces d'une
machine une grosse machine c'est un
ensemble tout donc tu peux pas venir
faire dans soif comme ça parce qu'il ya
du travail tout çà ou là
enfin ouais les acteurs c'est ça moi je
sais pas je m'étais acteurs mais si
j'étais acteur par exemple je devrais me
la péter un peu comme ça quoi
tentez chanteur c'est cool non c'est en
gros ce que je veux dire s'ils voulaient
qu'on la joue prise de tête je vous
faire une interview président vous
connaissez l'histoire on ne bouge pas on
nothing
[Musique]
bien alors ben justement donc comme vous
êtes acteur on va vous faire
le questionnaire de proust normal cela
pète on se la pète pas pour vous stomy
bugzy c'est quoi le comble de la misère
de la misère la galère soulevées ne pas
pouvoir nourrir ses enfants
ouais et vous de jamais pouvoir en
sortir
pour quelle faute avez-vous le plus
d'indulgence ça vous apprendra le
mensonge peut à peine bouger pas le
mensonge c'est vrai et vous aurez pareil
quel est votre personnage historique
favori là où l'autre malcom x où martin
luther king
je dirais benbella votre peintre favori
en tout cas c'est les impressionnistes
tête sézanne
ouais ouais oui j'y connais rien à la
qualité que vous préférez chez l'homme
courage et vous l'egypte à réussir non
non et non pas par une panne courage non
ce n'est pas une qualité que je préfère
chez l'homme aucune nous on est chez la
femme que vous respirez peut-être et la
sensibilité et vous ce tome i la
fidélité non par comparu lundi pour la
ville la vie pour la femme qui
auriez-vous aimé être si vous n'étiez
pas stomy bugzy qui par exemple j'ai pas
swami carca brad ne libère le libérateur
du cap vert on sera le pacino al pacino
et vous mais personne n'aura non vous
êtes vous ouais je suis bien moindre et
moi même très bien votre principal
défaut
là
las planas ria là il y en a plein et
maintenant c'est pour ça que c'est
compliqué plein de défauts j'ai pas
choisi répond d'abord l'asie tient
cherche et cherche un peu moi mais mon
principal défaut c'est que je pense que
je relativise beaucoup trop ça m'empêche
de d'être vraiment content que c'était
naturel un peu sombre non pas sont
justement non non je suis je suis très
drôle normalement mais si c est vrai qu
est ce qu est ce qui nous a récemment je
suis très très normalement j'ai j'aime
rire mais mais je relativise beaucoup et
ça m'empêche de de vivre pleinement ce
que je fais quoi votre principal défaut
cet ami
je ne sais pas non je ne sais pas là
tellement ses fastes ' responsabilisant
un poids mais des gourmands départ et se
tait coureurs mais non non non c'était
peut-être arrivé en retard mais j'ai pas
non non je sais pas franchement j'essaie
de ce pain défaut ça c'est leur cas
changer le don de la nature que voudriez
avoir et que vous n'avez pas voulu voler
vous l'avez déjà fait des questions à
battants qui vient jouer acteurs moi je
te la joues marcel proust en ce cas ça
t'apprendra t'inquiète pas je vais
revenir l'an prochain pour un album un
truc avant foutent la merde et si votre
devise yazid n'a rien sans rien ouais
mais vous baise la vie sinon être besoin
ou la paix de l'âme
à bastia j'y veille
jean françois stévenin thierry lhermitte
merci d'être venus merci hugo ça
s'appelle le roman de lulu c'est très
bien à bientôt et merci
m
à la fin de sa vie dans les dernières
années de sa vie françois mitterrand
avait un bon copain c'est georges marc
benamou
georges marc benamou bonsoir c'est vrai
qu'à la fin de sa vie est très copain
avec françois mitterrand son pâtissier
le mouvement fin mai s'il était son
confident
disons qu'on dit ça où j'étais ça et
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt ça
bien vous publié chez plon un livre qui
s'appelle jeune homme vous ne savez pas
de quoi vous parlez
c'est comment on fait georges marc je ne
fais pas pour ainsi si on le fait pour
soi d'habitude dans mais je vous le dis
vous faites les autres le font par
politesse mais ça vient je surveille
serait du ciel même l'exemple rappeur le
fond
alors quand vous lisez leurs rapports
gabriel de jean d'ormesson ou françois
mitterrand par l'ats jean d'ormesson du
lobby juif
vous savez que c'est vrai puisqu'il vous
l'avez dit il à employer ce mot là je le
raconte dans ce livre
dans une conversation qui situe environ
15 jours avant la conversation avec avec
jean d'ormesson
mais je ne suis pas d'accord avec
l'interprétation qui en a été fait on
peut pas en conclure que mitterrand
était antisémite on va en parler
interview vérité
[Musique]
bah oui le titre jeune homme vous ne
savez pas de quoi vous parlez fait
référence à un repas au restaurant la
mare est à paris dans le xviième vous
êtes avec françois mitterrand danielle
mitterrand qui a d'autres d'autres
personnes que j'ai pas envie de citer
bien alors à une table à côté il ya papa
maurice papon donc qui ne dîne pas avec
nous et je ne dîne pas avec vous vous
vous dites comme ça vous le vous
apercevez papon au fond de la salle et
vous dites
et dire que ce [ __ ] dinan ville pas de
réponse de l'it et rend pas de réponse
de sa femme
et dire que il a mis le même elles à
mettre des déportés dans des trains à
bordeaux que pour faire jeter des
algériens dans la seine en 61 c'est vrai
un silence bien sûr c'est vrai silence
vous rajoutez heureusement qui sera
bientôt jugée et la dernière mitterrand
évidemment le scoop un peul un peu naïve
elle dit à devant joue elle dit à
mitterrand mais papon il était très
sympa avec toi du temps de
l'observatoire
donc lhi la fusille du regard évidemment
pas ce que dit quand même elle et
gaffeuse maman est là il se retourne
vers vous avec un air terrible et il
vous dit vous ne savez pas de quoi vous
parlez
jeune homme est donc comme vous le
raconter avec beaucoup de mépris vous
dit ça
la mitraille commence et qu'est-ce qui
vous dit il dit ce qu'il a longtemps
souvent répéter cinquante ans après on
ne peut pas comprendre
cinquante ans après on ne peut pas tirer
un vieillard de son lycée ce qu'il
disait en cette scène est allé le
traîner en justice
c'est sa réticence à vouloir ouvrir les
placards de l'histoire dit bon on a fait
les purs à sion a été bien faite elle a
été trop fait elle a été mal faite ne
résoudront pas les plaies du passé
alors ça peut être une position de chef
d'état est ce que c'est la position de
notre génération je ne crois pas un mais
finalement tout le monde a dit ça et le
général de gaulle le premier à de gaulle
il a laissé pas pour en place qui sont
quand il jette des arabes dans la seine
par définition c'était de vaud le
président la république
oui enfin il c'est plus compliqué il le
laisse en place à la libération
d'ailleurs indiscutablement parce que
finalement de gaulle préféré avoir des
bons préfets ou sous-préfets vichyste
que des communistes ou des résistants
grandi ait été trop dangereux on les
expédiera en indochine d'ailleurs cela
donc on laisse en place la france de
vichy contrairement à ce qu'on pense au
fusil quelques stars on emprisonne
guitry etc
mais l'essentiel des élites qui a été à
vichy c'est pour ça que le procès ferrer
mitterrand est assez injuste parce qu'il
est laid parmi d'autres et c'est
vraiment un mal tenu que les autres mais
l'essentiel de la france était à vichy
c'est ce que j'appelle l'atlantide dans
mon livre les dames le concept on va y
venir
alors je veux rester sur ce dîner parce
qu'à la fin de de ce dîner cancan pape
on s'en va du restaurant il fait un
signe discret à mitterrand et c'est ça
qui vous a là vous comprenez d'un seul
coup la connivence entre ces anciens de
vichy d'une certaine façon il ya un
monde rit c'est le concept de l'atlante
il y à un disparu à vichy le 10 juillet
40 se précipitent toute la france les
administrations ce qu'il en reste
l'inspection des finances l'inspection
des finances on parle aujourd'hui des
inspecteurs des finances mais la vraie
naissance au pouvoir de l'inspection des
finances et vichy la préfectorale armée
en fait tout ça était à vichy alors à
partir de l'inter de vichy avait des
familles le concept de mitterrand est
qui qui l'emploie cette expression qui
l'emploie pour la première fois lors de
ce dîner
il y avait deux catégories à vichy il
est mal embarqué bien
et mitterrand était 10 est il un mal
embarquée bien arriver dans un accent de
vérité bien arriver en 43 et puis les
mal embarquée mme à l'arrivée cela avait
été peut-être ou moins malins ou moins
moreau ou moins courageux mais
finalement c'est laisser la bourgeoisie
qui sauf qu'ils sauvent les meubles quoi
les soudards de la collaboration ils
vont crever c'est assez singulier
dongeois sentir dans votre concept
d'atlantide c'est formidable merci non
mais c'est vrai parce que c'est
exactement ça et mitterrand vous le
découvrez d'un seul coup comme la figure
centrale d'un réseau d'anciens vichyste
auquel il rend des services en aidant
non il faut être précis c'est pas la
figure centrale d'un réseau d'anciens
vichyste il ya une souche politique qui
est à vichy et qui est un anti gaullisme
de droite il ya des relations qui se
nouent à vichy car c'est un être un
jeune homme très lent c'est finalement
très séduisant et beaucoup de gens se
raccroche à lui lui se crée des liens
mais il est pas et après guerre il
recycle un certain nombre de vichy il
n'est pas le réseau central il refuse
d'ailleurs assez courageusement occupe
je suis donc devenir gaulliste assez
courageusement parce qu'on pourrait
rares entrées dans gaullisme comme
chaban delmas comme couve de murville et
finalement se blanchir il décide de
faire sa vie sans de gaulle alors dans
son cabinet des anciens vichysme il ya
aussi georges dayan et des résistants
donc tout ça est un milieu dense très
république paraît complexe par rapport
aux autres membres aux autres atlante
puisqu'il avait l'atlantide il visite
les prisons il leur trouve du boulot il
explique dans il leur réserve cas de
résistance enfin m quand même ce que je
sais ce que je pense je ne crois pas que
ce soit une fidélité idéologique faut
que c'est le côté bizarrement bon bon
bon gars demi mais vous dites dans votre
book and j il ya une tendresse il a une
tendresse pour ces collabos qui sont en
prison ou l'amande sa soeur qui a été
octroyée aux questions juives et une
tendresse de celle que balzac à pour les
retrouver d'ancien régime
alors on aime on aime et un hochet qui
monte à la surface et picardes et sans
s'occuper des autres dit clairement une
sorte d'exil et servile et serviable
et pourquoi il a refusé toujours toute
allégeance au gaullisme par orgueil il
me dit un jour cette phrase pleine de
vérité j'avais décidé en 45 de faire
carrière dans l'anti conformisme en fait
tout le monde se précipite vers le
gaullisme tout le monde d'aller au
guichet la différence près que serra
donc qui sait dire où est ce que je vais
trouver ma place et c'est vrai que c'est
pas quand on est orgueilleux comme il
l'était c'est pas sa place et puis une
deuxième interprétation qui est la
mienne dans ce livre qui fait partie
d'une conversation d'octobre 1995
c'est ce fameux rendez vous le premier
rendez vous avec de gaulle toute sa vie
l'a raconté dans ça se passe en décembre
1943 le jeune vétéran arrive par des
circuits d'avion absolument impossible
et il est face à de gaulle et toute sa
vie il a raconté de gaulle a été très
antipathique ça s'est très mal passé il
y avait de l'électricité dans l'air il a
voulu me faire tuer après et tout ça
finalement je le découvre en avec dans
une conversation actuelle colonel passy
un certain nombre d'historiens en
attestent il a beaucoup aux olives et il
en a fait le socle de sa légende
rebelles à 27 ans contre de gaulle en
fait je crois qu'il ya une vraie
humiliation et vous c'est pas mal passé
mais qui mitterrand comme on dit un n'a
pas été calculé par de gaulle 1 et je
crois qu'il ya ça salit la manière donc
les gaullistes on parlait de mitterrand
ce mot c'est me tran ouais cette manière
négligente écrasé ben oui il a dû
l'appeler mimi tran il a dû être humide
et c'est vrai que jusque là jusqu'à ce
que vous en parlez tous les tous les
dieux hamel gispert les catherine née
état d'une opposition frontale qui était
fondatrice des frais de beaux livres
derrière eux et je leur je le rappelle
mais c'est ce qui nous a tous raconté
pendant des années et c'est vrai qu'à un
moment de sa vie il me dit vous savez ça
c'est pas si mal passé le rende avec
deux doigts le res qui se mettaient en
paix avec sa conscience s qui rectifie
encore un peu d'histoire et la pila
souvent rectifié parce que là la date la
durée
le fait qu'ils aient freiné ou pas
freiné enfin villa il a beaucoup varié
cette histoire il dit en arabe compteur
ce que vous dites ont à raconter des
bêtises sur cette rencontre
parce que plus étonnant dans votre
bouquin quand même c'est quand tu parles
de vichy fait à vie alors à pétain
c'était un vieillard un peu dépassée
mais magnifique mitterrand y avait ça il
y avait ça quand il a déposé il a
persisté déposé cette gerbe sur la tombe
de pétain en 92
j'ai eu cette conversation avec lui pour
la saturation c'est pétain c'est verdun
un verdun c'est le plus grand
traumatisme de l'histoire française avec
la shoah dit est il un million
trois cent mille morts c'est ça laisse
des traces dans le pays
je lui dis mais le pétain de 40 oblitère
le pétain de verdun qui est considérable
et je crois qu'il fait partie d'une
génération c'est ça notre divergence où
il pensait que verdun c'était aussi
important que 40
il était sur la ligne que décrit henri
amouroux 40 millions de pétainistes
c'est très curieux c'est très curieux
péan raconte sa fascination de jeunes
hommes quand ils le voient pour la
première fois au casino de vichy comme
ça il ya des lettres exalté et je crois
que quand on est vieux et c'était un
vieil homme d les souvenirs du cortex
jeunes remontent à la surface mais
probablement mais c'était pas la
fidélité idéologique je ne l'étais pas
c'est plus sentimental qu'idéologique
c'est sa jeunesse sa bohème les épaules
de danielle darrieux découvre au bord de
l'allier la [ __ ] et puis la
découverte du monde il s'enregistre à
l'ags et toute la france toute la france
et là sur un kilomètre carré
il parle de bousquet enfin vous parlez
de bousquet donc mitterrand regrette que
la carrière de bousquet a été brisée à
l'âge de 35 ans il regrette la façon
dont bousquet a été abattu par un
christian didier de curieux assez
curieux et puis le lobby juif donc on y
arrive on découvre que son plus grand
ennemi politique finalement
contrairement à tout ce qu'on a pu
penser c'était klarsfeld
oui le père serge j'en ai parlé avec
l'ars a levé rencontré en faisant ce
livre j'ai essayé de reconstituer ce qui
s'était passé pour moi et c'est
finalement la trame de ce livre il ya
une guerre de la mémoire
elle commence le 16 juillet 1992 au
monument du vel d'hiv c'est le 50e
anniversaire de la rafle des juifs de
paris mitterrand vient c'est la première
fois qu'un président français vient
c'est un événement énorme et il est lui
au bas d'un ter s'interpose dans un de
ces beaux discours que certains ont pu
contester
et là si je crois que c'est le premier
choc c'est une manif voulu en partie par
serge klarsfeld qui a un objectif
politique mais finalement de faire
reconnaître les responsabilités
françaises dans le low cost il l'écrit
l'a dit
70 ce qu'on peut dire pour les
téléspectateurs pour que tout le monde
suive bien c'est que klarsfeld
connaissait le passé un peu maréchaliste
dix ans de mitterrand et qui s'en sert
comme une épée de damoclès pour lui
faire accepter certaines choses
oui le père de klarsfeld était dans un
réseau d'ailleurs assez proche de celui
de mitterrand
et quand quand mitterrand fleuri la
tombe de pétain à l'île d'yeu ce que
vous êtes tous les présidents de la
république
tout le monde l'avait fait tout le monde
l'avait fait enfin le de gaulle l'art
est instituée en 67 parce que c'est le
50e anniversaire de verdun pompidou l'a
fait une fois ou deux giscard une fois
ou deux mitterrand était disons plus
assidus mal aux mamans alors que fait
klarsfeld il oblige mitterrand sous la
pression parce qu'il a il a des dossiers
d'une certaine façon à faire la journée
commémorative de la rafle du vel d'hiv
le 16 juillet ça se passe pas tout à
fait comme ça mitterrand s'obstine il
dit puisque klarsfeld me menace bien sûr
je vais plus m 2 de deux gerbes sur la
tombe de pétain je la mettrais surtout
te les tombes de tous les maréchaux de
14-18 et finalement la maladresse de
mitterrand ont fait que la crise est
telle qu'il effectivement accède à la
demande de la première demande de cirque
la suède cette journée de commémoration
du sénat et allié tout autour du 16
juillet parce que la guerre de la
mémoire elle se finit le 16 juillet 1995
trois ans plus tard et là c'est chirac
qui est président et il fait le discours
que klarsfeld attendait que mitterrand
n'a pas vous sauvez mon pendant ces
trois ans il ya une vraie guerre entre
mitterrand d'une part une partie des
responsables la communauté juive des
intellectuels à votre la jeunesse george
michael et c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est ça la phrase jeune homme vous ne
savez pas vous parler c'est finalement
la guerre de deux générations la guerre
2,2 moral et c'est ça que j'ai observé
d'ailleurs sans vouloir faire de
jugement de valeur parce que tout ça est
très complexe
mais pourquoi il n'a pas accepté de
reconnaître la culpabilité de la france
dans vichy il l'a fait il avait la
position il avait une position gaulliste
puisque de gaulle avait aujourd'hui ce
sera la france n'étaient pas fichés
l'été à londres donc ils avaient une
position bien gilles afférents quelques
petits pas fait je crois que les gens de
cette génération était très amer d on
peut pas ils ont essayé et tout le monde
a essayé de cacher ce qui s'était passé
pendant 40 ans on en parle beaucoup
depuis dix ans dans 40 ans on n'a pas
parlé effectivement la chape de plomb
gaulliste et effectivement il faut aussi
ne pas tomber dans le piège dans lequel
tombent parfois serge klarsfeld que par
ailleurs je respecte qui est de dire les
responsabilités de la france elles mêmes
que celles de l'allemagne
le français allemands tous à l'eau tous
des porteurs qu'il faut dire c'est que
la france avait perdu la guerre jorge
marque la différence quand même ce qu'il
faut toujours bien rappeler c'est grâce
à elle été envahie par l'allemagne
c'est toujours plus difficile quand on
est envahi par un parent un pays plus
fort que soi de faire ce qu'on veut un
double malentendu entre disons la france
de mitterrand et la communauté juive
pendant 40 ans on a gagné on n'a pas
parlé de l'holocauste ont à cacher on a
caché le responsabilité de la police on
a caché les responsabilités
administratives
on a caché tout ça est d'une certaine
manière il ya une vraie blessure dans la
communauté joue il faut dire que la
nation elle a été amputée d'une partie
de son ses membres et ce à la france ne
l'a pas accepté ce qui fait le chagrin
des juifs je crois aussi qu'il ya un
autre chagrin qui est le chagrin de la
france qui est que l' empire la deuxième
puissance mondiale s'est effondrée comme
un château de cartes de manière
inimaginable en huit semaines deux mois
entre le 10 mai le jour de l'offensive
allemande et le 10 juillet où la
république est abolie en deux mois la
deuxième puissance mondiale s'effondre
dans la honte avec des ministres qui
partent en pleine nuit
oubliant leurs dossiers la panique
généralisée et que ce traumatisme la cet
effondrement la de la france puis
d'ailleurs ensuite la guerre d'algérie
ça ça a été en tout cas cet effondrement
une blessure terrible aussi pour la
france qui a qui a rendu possible vichy
le vel d'hiv et toutes ces saloperies et
donc ça aussi
cette blessure l'a mitterrand l'avait il
ya une forme d'orgueil à ne pas l'avouer
guillaume georges-marc pour en finir sur
le bouquin n'est pas le seo réaction le
lobby juif
ils l'entendaient comme en mitterrand
quand ils vous disaient ça c'est
klarsfeld
c'est clair c'est grave c'est que la
restitution sa petite à cette petite
association très vaillante deux fils et
filles de déportés
je crois que ce mot finalement été
introduit par quelqu'un de son entourage
il ya qui a fait de mauvaises actions
n'ont pas besoin puritains mais ça on
fantasme toujours quand on lit lobby
juif en l'occurrence c'est klarsfeld
et puis un certain nombre de gens
motivés mais finalement la question de
vichy comme la question de la guerre
d'algérie comme tout ça c'est le
problème de la france bien georges
manqué beaucoup de réactions à votre
livre dans le point la semaine dernière
ils avaient des bonnes pages de votre
livre dans le point que cette semaine il
ya une lettre ouverte des amis de
françois mitterrand qui disent le
principal reproche qu'on peut faire à
françois mitterrand c'est d'avoir
accueilli des gens comme georges marc
benamou auprès de lui je veut rectifier
la place à la pétition charasse oui
assez la pétition charal c'est pas les
amis sont seulement de genre oui c'est
vrai qu'il n'a pas de pot unités enlevé
des jeunes nathalie qui a fait verbatim
c'est vrai que je suis confident un ami
journaliste fait jamais été conseiller
spécial ministre du budget médecin je
suis un individu libre ce qu'ils disent
dans leur pétition
il faut quand même dire que dix jeunes
cerfs que personne n'a lu ce livre ses
petits sur le texte était prêt avant que
le livre soit imprimé donc personne ne
la lui mais je n'ai pas lu dans le point
la semaine dernière ils ont peut-être
plus des extrêmes en fait ils ont lu les
bonnes pages 3% le livre et d'un livre
complexe et d'un livre un briquet d'un
livre que j'ai mis des années à écrire
ils ne l'ont pas lu et monsieur charasse
dit partout d'ailleurs je ne lirai pas
ce livre mais c'est un champ
vous pensez pas que le fait de faire un
livre où mitterrand reparle du lobby
juif ça peut réveiller l'antisémitisme
en france
non parce que je crois que j'ai fait un
livre au contraire très nuancée pour
expliquer qu'ils avaient ya eu entre
1992 et 1995 une guerre de la mémoire
entre est un vrai débat de haut niveau
parfois parfois tortueux je pense que
j'ai voulu montrer une complexité
française la france ça n'est pas que le
mal
la france n'est pas que le bien que nous
disait de gaulle ça n'est pas qu'une
france héroïque c'est une france plus
complexe enfin il renvoie en couverture
du point lobby juif et qu'on sait que
c'est un mode mitterrand vous pensez pas
que ça peu ses pattes s'est pas réveillé
uno ou accélérer l'antisémitisme là
parce que non non je pense que
l'antisémitisme petite chose trop
sérieuse pour puisse traiter à tord et à
travers les gens d'antisémite et c'est
pas le cas de mitterrand il ya eu une
brouille entre mitterrand et les
responsables de la communauté juive
à un moment donné sur une question
précise sur ce avec certains
responsables il faut le dire faut pas
écrire une histoire faite de langue de
bois elle est très complexe
on râle humain
vous savez pas de calais chez plon
quelques emails avant de recevoir mon
invité suivant des emails concernant
michael blanc alors pour aider michael
blanc il ya plusieurs solutions
possibles évidemment il ya tout le monde
envoie des emails il ya ceux qui disent
il faut envoyer des mercenaires pour le
libérer il ya ce c'est déjà plus malins
qui disent il faut boycotter les
vacances en indonésie et dire aux gens
de la jet set qui vont à bali depuis y
aller par exemple ça c'est déjà une
bonne idée et puis à stéphane lire odile
à shoot qui dit tous les spectateurs qui
ont fumé au moins une fois du cabanis
pour envoyer un franc sur le compte de
michaël blanc et c'est bon on pourrait
tous le faire est très riche il serait
très réussi tous les gens qui fumaient
du shit envoyé un franc il sortirait
tout de suite voilà donc le numéro du
site de michaël blanc s'inscrit sous
l'écran pendant que j'en parle et vous
pouvez aller sur le site et voir comment
l'aider en tous les cas la cassation est
prévue au mois de mai voilà à part ça
d'autres email patricia nathalie qui me
dit la plupart des gens font l'amour
pendant toute l'émission
et toi pendant quelle émission fait tue
l'amour c'est drôle
or nos grilles mais qui dit j'ai un
voisin qui écoutent jimmy somerville ce
doit être terrible d'avoir un voisin qui
secoue jimmy somerville ça doit être un
truc horrible
est ce que tu peux faire ton fameux
geste pour qu'il arrête alors je vais
faire le geste voilà voilà
j'espère que ça marche elle à la vigne
me dit je suis enceinte de huit mois et
mon bébé bouge pendant le jingle
s'emmerder c'est le plus jeune baptiste
de france
ma chère amie et nicolas il vient truc
il c'est incroyable quand tu as dit on
éteint la lumière les plombs chez nous
ont sauté
et
à
et maintenant mesdames messieurs les sea
dogs
[Musique]
il est issu d'un peuple qui a beaucoup
souffert voici dieudonné
[Applaudissements]
c'est très bien ça va les aider entendu
ce qui s'est dit au sujet de françois
mitterrand 1
vous en pensez quoi vous je ne suis pas
le seul être issu d'un peuple qui a
beaucoup souffert visiblement oui
visiblement et mai mais ça fait rire
quand il s'agit des noirs en général ils
arrivent
visiblement c'est l'fun dérange personne
alors que la misère et la douleur est au
moins aussi profonde et je remarque que
c'est la chanson de tonton david en tout
cas elle exprime cette douleur mais elle
est là pour présenter dans une sorte de
bonne humeur comme ça allez les noirs
c'est marrant vous êtes gentil alors je
les ai je trouve je trouve cela normal
je crois je suis pas tout seul à trouver
que c'est un petit peu pesant parce que
parce qu'on a on a souffert on a
vraiment souffert c'était pas pour
rigoler non mais je suis rentré je suis
rentré sur une chanson qui disait nous
sommes ici d'un peuple qui a beaucoup
souffert
je suis pas sûr qu'on connaisse il ya le
jazz aussi qu'il est mais il l'a fait
c'était c'était je crois dans le but de
vous dire quelque chose et je suis pas
persuadé que vous et que vous auriez
envoyé sept singles sur les propos de
monsieur tout à l'heure et je suis pas
persuadé que vous l'auriez fait je
trouve ça et je trouve ça regrettable
vous savez pourquoi j'ai mis cette
chanson j'ai donné non mais je sais pas
ce qu'on vous voit souvent à la télé et
maintenant vous voit à la télé à chaque
fois vous râlez justement et donc je
râle pas exact donc c'est vrai qu'à
achever le directeur moi même j'ai
beaucoup d'amitié pour ce que vous
faites je vous retrouver en plus très
drôle et politiquement souvent assez
justes et en tout cas courageuse de vous
battre à dreux mais je vous trouve un
tout petit peu parano achoui a baissé
tout est ce que tu me trouvais ce que
vous me prouvez parano produits taillés
il ya plusieurs avis je dis simplement
dit heureusement oui mais je trouve
simplement que il faudrait un moment
donné prendre au sérieux la souffrance
d'une partie de cette communauté
mais c'est une souffrance très sérieuse
il ya encore des gens aujourd'hui qu'ils
ont des problèmes pour se loger et c'est
souvent est systématiquement la même
communauté et je trouve que c'est que
c'est un peu regrettable
systématiquement de montrer un peu bon
allez
c'est à dire vous avez c'est pas l'envié
vous dit que malcom x où martin luther
king font partie d'un patrimoine
universel en face versé c'est pas chacun
défend son bout dehors alors moi je suis
prêt à me battre pour pour tous les
damnés de la terre et je crois que vous
aussi donc même pas non mais villa mais
comprenez un petit peu mon étonnement
quand je rentre dans une sorte de cirque
comme ça fait mal on sait pas quoi là
j'ai eu pire moi j'ai en fait je pense
que tonton david quand il a écrit cette
chanson il voulait dire quelque chose de
très de très profond voilà ce que je
l'aimé je vais me sur indre et ironique
et je découvre que finalement j'avais
raison vous avez perdu toute votre
ironie non il semble que je les garde
au contraire j'espère pour vous en tous
les cas non mais ne vous inquiétez pas
pour moi d'y arriver c'est gentil en
tout 4 vous préoccuper de mon ironie et
puis de maintenant ici que si on a du
mal à se faire abattre lui par exemple
pas avant il était super rigolo et tout
maintenant est devenu acteur il se la
pète
doigts c'est vrai non encore une fois on
peut pas dire je suis pas content de
chrétiens je suis très concerné par le
problème
simplement c'est vrai qu'à un moment ça
dit un casse couilles et à force de le
répéter je crois que vous servez pas
votre cause si je peux me permettre
alors moi ce que j'ai à vous dire si
vous me dites en tant que chrétien donc
déjà nous sommes français
vous me dites en tant que chrétiens à ce
qu'on souhaite c'est en tant que
chrétien vous appartenez à une
communauté tout à fait bon donc vous
tolérez que j'appartiens une communauté
oui laquelle
je sais pas moi quelle communauté vous
appartenez mois on avait dit oui donc
laquelle à votre avis à la communauté
des noirs 6 une communauté pour moi ce
n'est pas une mais bon je préfère le
concept de france et de république
oui place et on a passé un taux que je
crois que la france a tendance à trop
c'est ni 6 et que ce soit les familles
avaient parlé tout à l'heure de
communauté juive
nathalie c'est le sujet de mon livre et
ça ça m'intéresse c'est la suggestion
pour l'instant noah baumbach conception
les années ma couchette attendez
attendez option c'est que maintenant il
ya des juifs et y'a pas notre vision
parce que vous dire vous gonfler avec
vos histoires de chrétiens vous n'êtes
pas plus chrétiens vous en aurez public
vous êtes français vous vous êtes pas
juif vous êtes français années souffrant
c'est ce que je viens de dire eh bien
oui voilà deux mois je préfère la france
républicaine
effectivement et même même si j'ai mes
origines tu as tes oreilles tu sais qui
je pense est parlé pendant une
demi-heure de problèmes de la communauté
juive en parler de vichy ont parlé
d'autre chose enfin ces sujets n'ont par
ailleurs jamais comme tu en as et moi je
pense effectivement presque un monde où
les juifs se bat pour les juifs les
noirs pour les noirs les arabes pour les
arabes et les chrétiens pour les
chrétiens c'est un monde un peu triste
et je préfère la fraternité humaine moi
j'ai la laïcité mais voilà maintenant
quand je vous écoute et je reviens vous
avez parlé pendant trois quarts d'heure
du problème juif essentiellement mais de
laisser celle de vichy
l'histoire de france et oui c'est très
bien l'histoire de france mais il ya
aussi dans l'histoire de france et une
partie de l'histoire dont on ne parle
jamais ni dans les bouquins d'histoire
si ces trois cent ans d esclavage on
n'en parle pas on a rendu oral bazas et
je sais je ne m'en parle pas assez de la
guerre d'algérie qui est moins bien le
prochain
hier un fantôme à ouvrir moi je m'en
occupe pas qui va le faire ban espère
que c'est peut-être le vote prochain
bouquin c'est possible mais en tout cas
moi il est bien logique qu'à un moment
donné ayant accès à ces deux tribunes
j'explique mais même si je veux arriver
je rigole un petit peu parce que il faut
savoir rigolé un moment donné parce que
la situation est tellement kloppers il
savait rigoler en dire mais bon oui
venez voir mon spectacle juste à
l'olympia donc à partir du 23 juin et
[Applaudissements]
je vous répète que je trouve qu'à un
moment ça risque de desservir votre
course
ce côté sans arrêt comme ça devenir la
télé pour râler ça risque de desservir
votre cause la cause que vous défendez
les problèmes des noirs et n'ayant
jamais été réglé ils sont dans les
oubliettes sais pas si ça m'arrive
d'oublier
regardez le 22 mai sur de l'esclavagé il
n'est pas fêter ses un jour il ya en
fait la pentecôte mes couilles truc
enfin en fait fait en fait tout sauf le
jour de la terre joe de l'abolition
disque hommage 300 et 400 migrants
personnes vivront peut quand même
considérer que c'est une tragédie dans
l'histoire de l'humanité et qu'à un
moment ou un autre les huit sites un
souci permanent une horreur et quand on
va au sénégal là où partent et les
esclaves
d'ailleurs c'est un déchirement et c'est
pas simplement une rigolade un exercice
pour penser que c'est une rigolade je
dirais le combat des noirs américains et
le combat des droits civiques elle fonda
en france peut-être que les
effectivement les noirs français doivent
prendre exemple aussi sur sur une
émancipation je fais bien on va il veut
le film we 1 ça s'appelle voyant ses
manigances donc vous savez comment on
fait je suis issu d'un peuple qui a
beaucoup sur shay est 12ème du privé des
privilèges d'accord ça s'appelle voyant
ses manigances et avec vous avec
emmanuelle béart anémone serge
hazanavicius zinedine soualem
alors l'histoire c'est chantal qui est
jouée par emmanuelle béart donc
emmanuelle béart assez inattendu dans ce
film parce qu'elle a elle a retrouvé son
accent de cogolin
quand elle était petite des lunettes du
vernis à ongles bleu ont faim on est
loin les destinées sentimentales est
très marrante
elle a une vie paisible auprès d'un
dénommé rolland qui est jouée par
zinedine soualem dans une ville qui est
castel sarrasin tout va bien oui tout va
bien elle est fonctionnaire à la sous
préfecture
elle passe ses journées à retirer les
permis de conduire à des automobilistes
en infraction
en discutant et sa copine jacqueline est
interprétée par anne aymone elle a un
fils unique qui a été repéré par guy
roux qui est à auxerre ensemble de
formations et son mari roland et c'est
là que ça bascule bien entendu son mari
roland perd son travail et sur les
conseils de jacqueline d'anémone chantal
emmanuelle béart d
site de faire appel un service d'un
voyant alban qui est interprété par
dieudonné
vous l'avez compris qui est un fromage
ou jouer beaucoup l'auto dans le film au
tiercé et elle se laisse convaincre
qu'elle était envoûté par une voisine et
néanmoins ami qui s'appelle agnès et qui
est jouée par valérie bonneton voilà
effectivement par une série de hasards
les prédictions s'avèrent plausible et
elle commence à y croire sérieusement
[Musique]
e
tu as une idée du chiffre d'affaires de
la voyance en 99 20 milliards de
nouveaux francs cette norme le boulon le
pognon la santé ilcu bien sûr ils aider
la lucidité cet album tout ce qu'il m'a
dit j'avoue que je les ai vus s'est
trouvée confirmant nous y voilà
jacqueline tout signe divin
merci de votre aide vous avez pu le voir
à terre et feu armand parfait trait au
revoir en effet un jeu le voit très
nettement retravaillé et croit la
réincarnation doivent 1 français sur 2
crachent au bassinet pour les affaires
de prédiction de si ma tante en avait je
te dis il est infaillible mais je
comprends que tu sois côté frais mais
oui mais s'il ya des gens assez con pour
gobineau tôlerie qu'est ce que tu écris
pas possible c'est le nom du chien de la
voisine
on n'a jamais compris pourquoi envers le
détestaient nous y voilà chantal tout et
cindy vin vous savez tout est signé
d'évidence à la ça s'appelle mayence et
manigances dante et c'est vrai que
emmanuelle béart dans l'euro
de la cagole de castelsarrasin est
parfaite quant à vous de donner si je
m'inquiète de voir des fois un peu trop
sérieux c'est parce que je voulais déjà
dit après avoir le film de valérie
lemercier qui s'appelait le derrière
vous allez suivre un super acteur et
chaque fois que je vous vois je vous le
répète et c'est vrai je comprends et
envie de vous occuper d'autre chose
vous êtes tellement bon qu'on peut jouer
la comédie et vous étiez tellement bon
quand c'est un spectacle sur scène que
des fois on regrette un peu ce dieudonné
la voilà oui mais bon en même temps
d'être est tellement peu nombreux à
pouvoir parler c'est pour ça il faut
vous le disais tout à l'heure que l
avoir en main un moment donné et c'est
bien ouais il ya un moment qui est
vraiment marrant dans le film c'est
emmanuelle béart qui bavarde avec sa
copine anne aymone d'après
sous-préfecture là où elle travaille et
anémone lee marie claire et anémone lui
dit je trouve ça ridicule moi les filles
qui se font refaire les lèvres
la salle s'est marré à ce moment là elle
dit même ça ressemble à du foie de veau
alors j'en ai parlé avec emmanuel béart
qui m'a dit oui effectivement eric
fourniols smadi est ce que tu veux je
l'enlève
emmanuelle béart iliad innovant tu peux
le laisser ce qui prouve qu'elle a
beaucoup d'humour finalement alors ça
c'est le cinéma votre spectacle pardon
judas est en tournée et puis on le voit
aussi dans votre théâtre maintenant soit
vous jouez dans votre théâtre la main
d'or à doullens journée à l'olympia au
moins deux déjà par dont judas bien sûr
qu'il était pour chikyu pour porter un
sac ponot 2011 suivant
[Applaudissements]
in fine ton sac un renoi 200 m féminin
deux mille ans il te minos la top de
liège qui a fugué d'un tu te fais
qualité que tony et dati comme le voyage
du troisième le propre est le socialiste
et belge en pvc pâtes un nom dans l'anti
toi c'est pourquoi il s'est du reste
longtemps pourquoi parce que les
bouillouses à l'époque à qui était déjà
des boyaux de la moitié il nous avait
souri le symbole des où le christ avait
picolé devant pays laissant craindre il
est arrivé me coupa porte quel de dire
un truc
le symbole est où le christ a pris 3 les
bons que derrière que si tu picoler
dedans a battu le diabète et l éternité
le bourg était bourré plus de temps mais
je suis pas un mec bien
[Applaudissements]
raté incroyable il ya même un aveugle
qui est venu comme celle qui rêvait de
rang des mois la jeune fille pour la
faire il vous êtes payé pour rendre la
justice
à combien de photos combien il vous faut
mais dieu pour rendre la justice on peut
le savoir combien ça se paye la justice
moi on m'a traitée de presse pour 30 de
nîmes tu m'aimes pas 30 centimes
d'aujourd'hui me suis renseigné combien
vous faut-il à vous pour trahir la
parole de crise monsieur tirent chaque
fois que vous prononcez vous ferez vous
ne connaissez pas le pardon vous êtes un
traître et c'est judas qui voulaient
voir
argon judas dieudonné sur scène alors
joe dont vous avez une fille qui
s'appelle bonus à et elle doit souvent
vous posez des questions sur le monde
sur la vie sur les gens sur les idées
reçues
ça va vous falloir une interview
expliqué à ma fille en bouche par le
bouge pas pendant le génial
[Musique]
bien alors imaginez donc je suis votre
fille et je vous pose des questions pas
placé il faut bien petite rubrique
travail à faire enfin bon je pense pas
que ça soit très compliqué pour vous
papa c'est quoi un bon boulot c'est un
petit gâteau d'un petit gâteau qui s'est
vendu dans les années 80 et il y avait
un noir de cif
j'ai grandi avec ça c'était une
catastrophe et aussi le tête de [ __ ]
encore en pâtisserie qui se vend très
bien
c'est étrange que ce soit
systématiquement sur une communauté en
particulier que ce type de choses
arrivent c'est vrai c'est regarder les
réfléchissez pas d'autres pâtisserie par
n'y a pas de tête de chinois ou c'est
vrai oui un [ __ ] en chemise aussi ouais
pas pas toujours votre fille à un boni
pourquoi tu t'es pas présenté pour être
maire de dreux
parce que comme dans beaucoup de villes
de france mon enfant tu sais
la droite s'est allié au front national
pour faire liste commune dès le premier
tour il faut se retirer
faut se battre contre ces gens là a donc
je suis cette fois-ci retirer et
apporter mon soutien la liste de jean
pierre lesage entre bon bain contre la
folie ambiante
c'était un bien me faire un bisou aussi
séraphine a répondu pas paris dis moi
papa c'est vrai que tu vas être
président de la république
oui je serai le prochain président ma
fille je serai aussi le dernier
parce que c'est moi qui vais
démissionner cette fonction c'est du
rapide président après il n'y a plus
besoin de président qui croie ya plus de
prix a plus de frontières déjà 1,1
président de quoi wébo pop chacun des
présidents de chez soi chez sa carcasse
est d'accord avec ça je remarque est ce
qu'on devrait tous avoir une carte de
citoyen du monde et qui est plus de
frontières puis deux pays puis le
président jean ont fait l'europe ne
serait pas mal de gens fait loin moi
c'est pour çà président de la france bon
ça c'est pas complètement faux mais dit
pas que des conneries non dit papa pour
un bon bout d'un mois passent
[Musique]
papa tu avais dit qu'avec jeu ce pari
aurait plus de sans papiers et à la télé
on en voit encore c'est mieux et c'est
pas gagné ça clair et pourquoi toi papa
on ne voit plus trop à la télé bassi
regarde ma fille j'y vais et puis veut
parce que tu sais je fais j'ai fait des
films là j'ai joué au théâtre est venu
me voir majorque a bien aimé le
spectacle était monté sur scène un
hâtive affaires quotidiennes tu veux
faire comme il ya ferry tension fais
attention tu pourquoi pas parce que je
veux faire comme semi bugzy peux pas je
vais être acteur et pas pourquoi il n'y
a pas beaucoup de noirs à la td est
belle ma fille tu sais ça s'est fait
doucement il y avait un code noir et une
justice qui déterminait que l'homme noir
n'était pas égale à l'homme blanc même
un pape qui a dit que l'homme noir
n'avaient pas de conscience tu sais ça
remonte à l'ong allemande revient le
dise ah oui oui oui dernier n'a pas dit
ça évidemment mais
mais il est issu d'une vieille tradition
et puis c'est un c'est un monde qui a
considéré que le boire mais n'était pas
un homme et un sous-homme et encore
quand on va chercher du boulot quand on
va aux loges et quand tu iras j'espère
que ça sera à ranger d'ici là mais tu
aura plus de problèmes que les autres
il va y avoir plus de noirs à la télé
oui je pense qu'il y en a déjà un peu
plus donc ça va mieux
oui bien sûr l'espoir les devants toute
façon la merdasse c'est derrière pas
pourquoi le président de république
jacques chirac
il va pas voir le juge qui l'a convoqué
parce que tu sais mon enfant en ce
moment il ya une chose très importante
qui est en train de se passer derrière
ces artistes qui détient les bonnes
valeurs et la morale la justice ou les
élus train on ne sait plus tu essaies on
est dans un système en intense et de
justice c'est la même qui emprisonne des
sans papiers qui tolère le commerce des
bombes et des armes et de l'autre côté
tu as un homme qui qui lui représentant
commerce justement et puis en même temps
ça lui donnerait qu'elle parle de
jacques chirac maître lui en a jamais
parlé
papa c'est quoi les verts pourquoi ils
sont pas tous vers les verts allons peut
être noir et vert regard stéphane c'est
comme les stéphane pocrain et ben les
verts c'est c'est une force politique
qui commence à grandir dans ce pays
et puis il faudra bien toute façon que
toi que ça se renouvelle et puis là il
ya un nouveau parti qui est plus proche
plus proche des autres plus proche de
l'environnement regarde en afrique quand
tu vas chez grand père chez papi mais si
des gens qui vivent pas pareil avec leur
environnement sont des verts aussi sur
des écolos sont des gens qui au
quotidien vivre dans une autre relation
qui sont pas dans une hystérie de la
productivité comme certains bon il ya
des avantages et des inconvénients
tu as vu quand tu vas chez papy il n'y
avait pas d'eau chaude c'est bien bon
papier j'aime bien léché papilles ouais
et papa c'est vrai qu'il faut plus
manger de danone ah oui ça c'est vrai ah
c'est vrai parce qu'à l'école on m'a dit
on mange plus de bananes chez nous on
mange plus d'âme
voilà pourquoi parce qu'il faut partir
et c'est mauvais ça donne la chiasse
est papa j'ai entendu et lu ton ancien
copain qui a dit à la radio que tu pensé
qu'au fric
bah oui parce qu'il fallait bien qu'ils
trouvent quelque chose mais tu sais
bombe à lui il a vendu beaucoup de
cassettes a eu beaucoup plus d'impôts
papa donc ça les énerve un petit peu
près mais bon c'est son copain a pas
d'accord c'est quand même son copain pas
la wii un copain reste encore pas bien
il vaut mieux aimer jésus ou coluche
sont les mêmes ce sont deux grands
humoristes de l'histoire et papa comment
roule un joint
tiens va chercher la boîte là bas est
papa pourquoi on meurt c'est très
important
c'est très important ça arrivera un
moment où tu prévois pas et c'est mieux
comme ça et est pas si tu meurs pas tu
vis pas toi c'est la mort la mort ça
n'existe pas si on vient obligé de
mourir en fait c'est une mauvaise
question je sais pas qui tu as posé
cette question ça allait passer à
l'école c'est la petite la petite semoun
un petit cerveau c'est la petite semoun
qui m'a dit demandent ils à ton père
téléphone à son père son ballet lever
ces gens là c'est parce que tu vas
mourir que tu rigole moins qu'avant
non je tu sais je rigole toujours autant
tu m'as vu quand même bon à la maison
c'est vrai que tu as fait des bêtises
aussi c'est normal que je rigole pas
tous c'est vrai mais c'est vrai je reste
à ma puce
enfin
enfin non non tu chez papa il a toujours
rigoler en afrique a énervé pas passer
deux jours où tu m'as trouvé en train de
lire minutes tu te souviens voyez quand
ton frère est rentré dans la police
elle arrive brute est ainsi sandrine
martin
vous avez ça c'est bien le faire ça
bravo alors vous arrivez donc de la
comédie de paris rue fontaine vous jouez
deux surprises en confidence jusqu'au 14
avril avant d'aller jouer la même pièce
au palais des glaces rue du
faubourg-du-temple à partir du 17 avril
alors vous jouer mais vous êtes aussi
auteurs co metteur en scène avait kamel
jemel les autres acteurs c'est charlotte
des georges laurence oltuski thierry
godard perkins lyautey c'est son vrai
nom perkins lyautey c'est un mec génial
de s'appeler perkins tuyautés oui oui
c'est son vrai nom est bien et arié
elmaleh qui est le frère de gad elmaleh
voilà baixas le pitch alors de surprises
en confidence est basé sur le huis clos
c'est un huis clos où des personnages
comme dans tout les huis clos révèlent
leur vraie personnalité
ça c'est assez classique ce qui est
moins classique c'est le lieu où ça se
passe c'est dans une salle de bain voilà
parce que sophie l'idée très drôle très
marrante sophie organisé un anniversaire
surprise pour son fiancé paul et la
bande d'amis se cache dans la salle de
bain pour préparer la surprise ces
fameuses anniversaire sur supporte pas
ça m'est arrivé une fois j'ai interdit
ça pour toujours parce que là c'est pire
parce que la porte reste fermée
tu veux dire que ce film un peu art
addict et donc elle a une porte en rien
acquérir qui permet à l'intérieur tous
de la salle de bains est très snob 7
sophie et donc le téléphone sonne et à
ce moment là on entend son fiancé paul
qui dit message sur répondeur
voilà et puis je suis très déçu tu n'es
pas penser à mon anniversaire et il vaut
mieux qu'on se sépare
voilà en fait c'est rien ça oui ça oui
c'est un raccourci il téléphone une
première fois parce qu'il l'a cherché
c'est une femme qui est un peu
aller à droite à gauche chez l'un
joignables en permanence donc lui ça
l'énervé ils rappellent ils rappellent
on ne peut pas décrocher vu qu'on est
enfermé donc c'est vrai qui finit par
appeler pour dire
pour dire en effet qui rentrera pas
parce que il y en a marre de cette vie
et voilà voilà
on fait le point sur leur relation il
trouve que finalement c'est pas si bien
que ça donc en effet il préfère lui
annoncé qu'ils se séparent donc ils vont
tous restés dans cette salle de bain
évidemment comme dans tout les huis clos
devons tous dire et vous on vous sort de
la salle de bains par le hublot parce
qu'un hublot et vous sortez par la
fenêtre de la salle de bain oui
[Musique]
je me fasse un peu plaisir en émission
aussi un bon alors bientôt le palais des
glaces
ça marche bien alors ça veut dire jeu
super bien au mois de septembre on a
commencé avec un ter de 50 places donc
le mois de mai 500 classes c'est vrai
que ces jeunes et heureuse ça fait
plaisir
on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble mal
et de réflexion faite c'est sa petite
robe qui fait une épaisseur de trop aux
rayons à faire ça si on est obligé d
avis et alain non non à trois on va la
pousser tout neuf sera pas savoir elia
apprendre à vous pousser toutes nos
forces à bâle ont surtout un e3 et ben
c'est bien beau de bouffer les bars
l'arrivée de la mettre à poil autant lui
poser la question
bondy demande elle veut pas celle qui
décide et bien à vous d 102 minutes
peut-être un truc voilà bon on pense que
c'est votre petite robe way qui fait une
épaisseur de trop parce que sinon ça
passe par quatre c'est pas que ça passe
pas c'est que ces profils à seriez vous
d'accord pour l'homologuer d'accord mais
tous les yeux sur les engorgements c'est
normal de sa marge en même temps
seulement l'été en culotte et soutien
gorge pour montrer que la pièce est
évidemment ça aide c'est pas nouveau non
moi je non je ne me déshabille pas non
mais c'est pas c'était pas c'était
patiemment c'est à dire qu'au départ
j'ai pas écrit le rôle pour moi mais
c'est vrai que le personnage des liens
ne se déshabiller pas mais quand j'ai
écrit la pièce je savais pas du tout
quelles robes j'allais jouer et il se
trouve que le hasard a fait que
finalement vient finalement on va
peut-être aller plus loin sur ce terrain
là vous allez voir en et bouge pas
pendant le génial
[Musique]
bien plus cette interview psy vous
connaissez non en fait si le juge est
mythomane mito un peu un peu parano
beaucoup schizo non maso un peu voilà
vous aimez bien souffrir un peu
psychologiquement ou physiquement j'ai
un doux mélange des deux ah ouais quand
même
ou bien de passer ou mordus ça peut
arriver et ça donc ça va avec un petit
peu aussi un peu sado maso vous avez une
robe vinyle chez vous vous êtes homo
j'ai essayé ça vous a pas plu si c'était
très excitant non vous êtes vibro non je
vous êtes trio nous plaît vous avez
jamais essayé non non non mais non là
dessus et encore je veux bien le croire
la toute petite là le petit babou 1
j'étais pas là ce sont encore ces
censures non quand elle était petite et
pas ce genre de chose quand elle était
petite voix dans les bois dont vous
n'avez jamais essayé non plus ce trio
non vous devriez essayer
franchement non je crois que ça doit
rester des fantasmes éthiques
c'est de l'ordre du fonds vous êtes
gérant tôt c'est à partir de quel âge
non je déconne 50 points parce que
j'avais pas du tout géronto pas un peu
notre ami avait cédé vous aviez terry
lhermitte à côté de vous pas du tout
imaginé chéri le vrai thierry lhermitte
et s'avoue mme nom et vous les vieux
n'ont pas forcément vieux mais ont pu
merveille pédo non à dos même pas les
ados ou exhibo bah si tu avais un peu
exhib haut mais chez vous aussi ou
simplement sur la scène oui chez moi je
suis tranquille ouais je suis seul il ya
des gens qui ont des voisins qui
regardent pas d'exhiber c'est bien ce
que je dis est ce que vous êtes fétiche
oh non non pas du tout porno vous
regardez des cassettes pornos ça peux
m'amuser mais seul solo peut-être solo
finalement peut-être d'infos non pas du
tout pippo nom et disco très
et maintenant mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
voici roj
bonsoir
donc on est serré vous que tout le monde
connait rails je sais pas moi je vous
connais en tout les cas vous appelez pas
vraiment rails en plus de flairer mundo
souza vieira de oliveira dire aïe
enfin plus facile vite le frère de
socrate est quand même une sacrée
famille un international de l'équipe du
brésil à 22 ans rapidement capitaine de
la seleçao 65 sélections 30 buts
meilleur joueur sud américain en 92 et
en 93 vous débarquer au psg où vous
retrouvé vos copains valdo et ricardo et
vous partez du psg quelques années plus
tard en 97
après un joli doublé la coupe de france
et la coupe de la ligue
vous rentrez en 95 à sao paulo et vous
achevez votre carrière de footballeur
pro en juillet 2000 et l'a récemment
vous jouer un dernier match un match
amical contre flamengo en janvier 2001
donc juste pour votre fondation en fait
non on n'a pas fait le c'est un match
jubilé ouais on va faire la mois de
juillet peut-être que peut-être même
avec le paris saint-germain lavalloise y
est on va aller faire un match et jubilé
ici à paris on est en train de discuter
ça avant mais peut-être au mois de
septembre il fasse face toutes les
recettes ce sera pour la pour la
fondation la fondation qu'on a il faut
savoir c'est que rails après cette
magnifique carrière donc d'abord dans
l'équipe du brésil et ensuite au psg
vous avez créé une fondation qui
s'appelle gol de letra que vous avez
initié vous et financé vous avec votre
ami leonardo alors on va parler un petit
peu de la réalisation de cette fondation
il ya vous avez fait ça en outre 99 ça a
commencé
c'est sur une colline à côté de sao
paulo qui s'appelle très même mais on
appelle ça la colline des poux mais
là-bas 50 % des adolescents ont moins de
4 ans d'école derrière eux c'est une ltv
liliane surtout sont ces genres d
d'enfants qui est qu'habite dans les
banlieues défavorisées
donc ils vont c'est qu'on essaye de les
apporter
c'est pas de ned comme ça c'est pour les
apporter c'est qu'ils ont le droit c'est
à dire des limites des opportunités une
bonne éducation une bonne note des
impôts signer pour faire des activités
pour qu'ils connaissent plein de choses
l'informatique de ça pour qu'il puisse
se débrouiller tout seul après oui en
fait c'est pas pour en faire des
footballeur parce que vous vous luttez
beaucoup contre le mythe du football
parce que vous dites que finalement il
ya 1 % des jeunes brésiliens qui
deviennent des stars du football et ça
fait 99 % de gens qui sont déçus ouais
c'est vrai surtout dans cette classe la
plus défavorisée
il y voit le foot comme une façon d de
s'en sortir et il ya peu de gens qui
arrivent dans kiss on essaie des néo
croire à leur portée celle d'une façon
comment être humain côté citoyen et
comme ça il peut s'en sortir de
plusieurs façons dufermont dit alors ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que ça a des
résultats parce que dans le centre là
qu'il a créé et le taux de redoublement
est de 5% alors que dans le reste du
brésil il est de 40 %
c'est vrai qu'au brésil y'a pas une
grande solidarité entre les classes
sociales a ouais ça n'avait pas ça
commence on allait plus en plus de la
société civile qui commence à bouger un
peu ouais mais c'est un des parce que
c'est un pays riche quand même et qu'on
a commencé
c'était le septième et huitième économie
du monde
mais c'est un des pires des grandes
oeuvres de partage de certains joueurs
est très mal fait à l'injustice sociale
très importante donc il ya des moyens
qui on puisse faire un pays c'est que
juste donc ça s'appelle gol de letra et
est ce que vous allez faire d'autre
d'autres centres au brésil et dans le
monde
ouais là où on va commencer en deuxième
le mois de juillet à rio
ouais c'est uen et leonardo en couple au
caire qui avec moi et on va faire ses
deuxièmes après pendant deux trois ans
on va voir une expérience qui on veut
après créer un utiliser des mots des
méthodes d'éducation que vos après
passer à d'autres sites ou de 6 ans aux
mêmes of faire des échanges avec les
écoles publiques
alors vous venez d'une famille très
étonnante votre père autodidacte s'est
plongé dans la philosophie grecque et
alors les enfants de la famille
s'appelle socrates fameux footballeur
évidemment sophocle ce stand et et vous
si votre mère n'était pas intervenue
vous seriez appelé platon donc elle est
intervenue alors enfant vous rêviez pas
du tout d'une carrière de footballeur
non malgré un frère vous aviez votre
idole à déjeuner à dîner tous les jours
étaient cotées cette année
n nna moi j'étais fier de lui mais je
pensais pas être est très joueur j'étais
un jeune brésilien kaka mais le foot
mais peut pas être pro mais c'était une
chose qui est qui était naturellement où
j'étais tout naturellement pas tellement
ri c'est à dire qui en fait un jour
votre amie christina s'est retrouvée
enceinte exactement ça va tomber en soit
la chaussette commencerait pas juin
alors mais malgré tout pendant votre
carrière vous disait toujours je vais
reprendre mes études je vais reprendre
mes études quand j'aurai fini ma
carrière de footballeur
et c'est ce que vous avez fait
d'ailleurs dès que vous avez eu un peu
de temps vous avez recommencé répondre à
la philosophie samassa mais ça m'a
manqué c'est possible ils sont un peu le
sol ma famille elles sont bien alors
vite marié à 17 ans avec cristina donc
et vous êtes toujours ensemble non non
non plus on a passé des espoirs je suis
persuadé vous étiez toujours ensemble
non mais l'entente non mais là on
s'entend très bien on a passé 16 ans en
plus on n'est plus ensemble depuis deux
ans mais en me sentant toujours très
bien et je les considère comme marié et
aussi parce que c'est pas facile contre
commençait à 17 ans elle avait 13 ans
oui on a passé quand même 16 ensemble
c'était moi je sais j'ai plein des
bombes semaine mais c'est marrant alors
je vais vous dire quand vous êtes venu à
paris au psg
elle a très mal pris la vie en français
ça lui plaisait pas du tout la vie en
france
et quand vous rendriez à croissy le soir
chez vous elle pleurait elle était
triste et votre couple a survécu à ce
passage difficile en france et ça s'est
arrêté après une fois que j'ai trop
tourné au brésil
ouais mais ça n'a pas duré longtemps
le premier 6 7 mois parce qu'il surtout
à cause des enfants les enfants et
habitant à s'adapter aux nouveaux si
c'est une façon différence des vivres
mais on avait envie dst de connaître
notre réalité c'est ça qu'on a fait on a
passé cinq ans en france a noté aurait
aussi est bon c'est ça après on est aux
nombreuses et c'était après qui apprécie
alors au brésil et y est donc une énorme
star donc comme je le dis en 92 meilleur
joueur d'amérique du sud
sex-symbol on vous appelez match numéro
un et 1 mètre 90 90 kg enfin bon tout ce
qu'on n'est pas et pourquoi avoir choisi
le psg plutôt chrome ou madrid
en france même si les gens adorent le
foot sont pas fous comme ont comme en
italie
la pression n'est pas bouger les joueurs
n'ont pas le temps d'aider connaître la
ville quand la vie est ici en france
nous les gens les aiment bien on a beau
rapports avec les supporters mais aussi
on a à côté en prélevant une vie lisse
et même en espagne ou en italie à la
première saison au psg c'était assez dur
pour vous vous marquez pas beaucoup vous
tourner un peu comme ça vous errez un
peu sur le terrain vous appelle fantômas
avec toi avec ce n'est pas très sympa et
en fait ce que si vous sortiez de 170
matches en deux ans quatre par semaine
vous êtes arrivé au psg était un peu
fatigué oui à passer j'ai passé deux ans
et demi en faisant plein match et
pendant les vacances j'ai juste joué
pour l'équipe nationale
j'ai passé deux ans et demi sans avoir
des vacances en arrivant ici
vous arrivez avec
les gens attendaient beaucoup de moi
j'étais fatigué je ne pouvais pas être à
l'auteur qui on attend mais j'ai eu la
passion puis avec lima il y avait les
terrains qui était détrempée les
terrains qui étaient qui était dur
problème comme on l'a dit avec votre
femme qui les prennent pour s'acclimater
ouais ça a commencé en deuxième saison
leur deuxième saison c'est parti vous
avez marqué 12 buts en 20 matches et
vous êtes revue devenu une star
assez rapidement finalement alors après
ouais après ça saleh moi j'étais j'étais
content paris on en a gagné plein de
bonnes choses avec des supporters si
j'étais content décidé d y est aussi
parce que souvent où il ya plein d
surtout les sud-américains conseiller si
celui-ci le premier
parfois il rentre ouais moi je voulais
aussi aussi on a une jument s'est joué
vous avez terminé sur la coupe de france
coupe de la ligue
alors on va vous regarder on va voir non
seulement marqué mais aussi pleuré
[Musique]
voilà un but de rattraper
reste deux minutes dans leur tiré par
leonardo et bien non les klaxons
et ça fait deux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le produit
[Applaudissements]
la chercher il l'a trouvé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
alors comme dans votre carrière on
l'avait vous avez eu des hauts et des
bas on va faire une interview hop en
daran ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous préférez en vous aux
militaires vous êtes humble la chose que
vous détestez en vous parfois je suis
trop ouais ouais hommes le trouble si
vous préférez dans le foot c'est le
contact avec le public nous frisons
on a vu ce que vous détestez dans le
football c'est quoi pas grand chose mais
au fond on exagère dans le foot soit on
lui met le joueur l'équipe là bas mais
aussi quand on vole et ouais c'est un
peu trop certaines fois un peu trop bas
d'autres fois oui votre match préféré
dans toute votre carrière
j'ai eu une finale intercontinentale
quand je vais à 100% par l'eau barcelone
c'était la finale du mondial interclubs
moi j'ai marqué deux buts ont été
champions du monde
ouais je m'inquiète de but à la finale
et votre pire match
au pire il ya une pas mal des moments
difficiles je ne gagne pas des souvenirs
ouais voilà ce qui vous fait le plus
marrer dans la vie c'est quoi c'est que
ma fait peut être heureux c'était cet
anneau nation c'est ma fille quand
j'avais 18 ans j'étais un corps moi
j'avais pas casqué qu'est ce que ça
représentait donc gt gt pur sentiment je
ne sais pas j'avais pas exactement la
responsabilité que c'est important
qu'ils étaient euros ça me fait des
maris aussi est ce qui vous fait le
moins marrer dans la vie mois marié le
jure que je sue qui est ma femme était
enceinte
ça fait le déplacement après j'étais
aurait un tout vingt neuf mois avant le
plus gros coup de fric ce qui vous a
rapporté le plus d'argent
le plus d'argent donc j'irai tournée au
brésil à sao paulo si on avait fait une
belle carrière sont parvenus à paris je
fais un signe j'ai eu un bon moment ici
à paris il ya semble sans parler des
parements moments qui m'ont fait venir
avec un bon contre un oui est votre plus
grosse perte
moi j'ai pas j'ai pas trop dedans
dépense trop cher loin dès que c'est
trop cher je préfère penser que vous
avez la fondation là tout respire le bon
goût de faire mes plus belles histoires
d'amour
c'est vrai que chine - mick st ouais ça
j'avais 16 ans et la marianne auxenfans
la pierre je crois qu un corpo vignes
vous êtes prêts qu'est-ce que vous avez
de plus sexy en vous des plus sexy on
dit que la bouche
ouais sandrine qu'est ce qui l'a le plus
c'est que ça ira en même temps j'ai vu
le corps aussi en même temps et vous
voudrez pas géronto lancée mais quand
même ce qu'il a le sourire aussi oui
vous aussi je faisais de moins sexy
c'est moins sexy je peux le pied pied du
footballeur ouais c'est pas beau les
pieds de footballeur
tous d'accord ce que vous préférez dans
le sexe je préfère
bien sûr il ya un moment d'extase in
mais je préfère ces moments qui vient
avant la préparation et quand on monte
l'escalier comme disait l'autre
est ce que vous détestez dans le sexe
maintenant on est obligé de dire au
revoir quand ça passe rien n'obligeait
voilà et merci beaucoup
on va passer au bla ites maintenant
et j'accueille pour arbitrer ce blind
test mois sur philippe bordés
le moment
n'hésitez pas
mais je connais vous
m
c'est une fois ce petit je ne sais quoi
qui fait que ce soit alors on fait la
revanche pour faire plaisir au capitaine
de la seleçao le brésil alors le brésil
ici vous l'avez vu avec les plumes et la
france ici à dakar
d'accord georges-marc vous êtes en
relais dans l'équipe du brésil dont vous
connaissez le principe du blind test je
veux l'interprète pas le titre de la
chanson je veux l'interprète
ce soir c'est un spécial anatomy voilà
donc il sera soit que des parties du
corps
didier première chanson qui chante plus
haut qui chantent
voilà
comme on l'a bien compris vous avez un
secret c'est sa petite amie vous avez
compris je veux le nom du chanteur
allait ou de la chanteuse bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
me répondre c'est le premier qui répond
gallimard voilà donc c'était etienne là
où on en est où là sur les points lamar
tous très bien jean son numéro 3 on
souffle par
oui
attention
aurait on ne souffle pas asser le public
peut répondre si les invités ne trouve
pas évidemment le public peut répondre
c'est ronaldo ou à faire un tel dossier
c'est bien donc là ça fait donc deux
pour le brésil est un pour la france
didier
comment
j'adore de ligue 1
vous de duchamp djabla
[Musique]
scarlett
des grands
les grands
seules les grandes oreilles
les brésiliens ce qui me fait bravo
voilà francs
si ça répond la bassée visite petit avec
des grandes z'oreilles big baxter didier
[Musique]
et
vous avez vu le tout résumé à greenway
didier
lauryn hill à penser toujours bon enfant
bravo on est à combien l'a24 c'est la
france qui gagne
l'intérêt
j'ai eu
elle a dit oui
serge petit riblet harry tripoli
attention
oui
martin encore ça fait quand même cinq
pour la france et 2 pour le brésil va
avoir 30 minutes didier
[Musique]
je
alors là
on va faire je pense cendrillon on à
romane bohringer on avoue on a bâti on
va faire pour la dernière émission la
fin de l'année on va prendre toutes les
stars du blind test est très très chaud
cette forte michel rocard merci
catherine missionne retard excellent
goûter bien au corps
mais
le ralenti plus belle celle là on peut
l'avoir cherché tu étais là il revient à
la première note
c'est très fort ça très très fort
et voilà maintenant l'avant-dernière
attention
[Musique]
il a dit
appiah répandue
qu'est-ce que à seissan à peine pourtant
à donner une revanche au brésil
le score est de 8 pour la france et 2
[Applaudissements]
il savait pas
c'est la date limite maintenant il ya le
super banco donc le super banco
celui qui trouve le super banco gagne
tout dire que même si c'est vous
évidemment vous ferez que regagner ce
que vous a déjà gagné mais ils peuvent
emporter le match grâce au superbe
encausse établissements c'est injuste
mais la vie est injuste
didier qui chantent
très grave là quand le souffle base est
très grave oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en effet justin
m
bonjour
un groupe
c'est la france donc il encore
définitivement je suis désolé pour vous
merci merci à tous d'être venus c'était
tout le monde en parle avec thierry
lhermitte à la fiche du film de pierre
olivier scotto le rendement de lui
18 avril avec les africaines patrick
bouchitey et pierre olivier scotto
mélanie
à la fiche du film de patrick
alessandrin 15 ou le 18 avril avec
richard berry charles berling et jean
pierre darroussin familles voisines
la ville de jean françois richet de
l'amour
avec virginie ledoyen yazid
marceau groupe et jean françois st
toulouse actuellement en tournée les
nazis de pau
revoir il c'est de l'amour
dieudonné qui a donné la fiche du pin de
rognage voyant ses manigances avec
emmanuelle b
anémone à jour vient
pardon gildas georges marc benamou des
groupes de jeunes hommes
pas de quoi vous parlez aux éditions
plon merci georges a dream
deux surprises en conscience un comédie
2 baril plus en scène par ahmed gmail et
sandrine martin est bien fait don au
palais des glaces ainsi sa à partir du
pis à brive à la haye l'ex capitaine du
psg
et puis du vrai jour
l'association
bon d'elektra voilà c'était tout en en
parle
rendez vous la semaine prochaine
et
m
nous
tous
non
[Musique]
mon île
mes yeux
oui
m
jusqu'où
et qui
[Musique]
et qu il
pour
non
[Musique]
l'eau
et
[Musique]
il
et puis moi
jusqu'où
et qui
[Musique]
alors plein de damas